chaque collègues je vous propose
de vous installer nous allons commencer
avant de d'entamer la le sujet principal
de notre commission ce matin à savoir la
table ronde consacrée à la transition
écologique du bâtiment du bâti anciens
nous avons désignation
à effectuer concernant la proposition de
loi portant réforme de la loi du 9
février
1895 sur les fraudes en matière
artistique déposée en décembre dernier
par notre collègue Bernard fialer et ses
collègues du groupe RDSE que nous
pourrions examiner en séance à la
mi-mars sur la niche du groupe RDSE je
vous propose de confier la conduite de
nos travaux sur ce texte à notre
collègue Bernard feeler auteur de la PPL
s'il n'y a pas d'opposition
il en est ainsi décidé
mes chers collègues nous allons
monsieur chenech vous pouvez venir mes
chers collègues nous allons commencer la
table ronde consacrée à la transition
écologique du bâti ancien il y a
quelques semaines Sabine Draxler notre
rapporteur nous avait sur les crédits
budgétaires nous avons alerté à
l'occasion de la présentation de son
rapport sur le projet de loi de finance
pour 2023 sur le défi soulevé par la
transition écologique du bâti ancien
les immeubles datant d'avant 1948
représente environ un tiers de notre
parc immobilier leur rénovation
thermique et donc un enjeu important
dans le cadre de la lutte contre le
changement climatique
seulement le
leur transition ne peut pas se faire à
n'importe quel condition dans la mesure
où il constitue un patrimoine qui nous
faut aussi préserver afin d'approfondir
notre réflexion nous nous accueillons ce
matin 5 intervenants pour partager avec
nous leur point de vue sur cette
problématique monsieur françois de
Mazières maire de Versailles ancien
directeur général de la Fondation du
patrimoine ancien directeur de la Cité
de l'architecture du patrimoine et qui a
écrit des tribus une tribune il n'y a
pas très longtemps sur ce sujet dans le
Figaro notamment monsieur Boris Ravignon
présidente de l'Agence nationale de la
transition écologique l'ADEME et
également maire de Charleville-Mézières
Monsieur Jean-François Hébert directeur
général des patrimones et de
l'architecture au sein du ministère de
la Culture monsieur Fabien Sénéchal
président de l'Association nationale des
architectes et bâtiments de des
bâtiments de France architectes des
bâtiments de France à la DRAC de
Bretagne
et Madame Grégory du Tertre directrice
du conseil d'architecture d'urbanisme et
de l'environnement de Seine-et-Marne qui
intervient aujourd'hui au nom de la
Fédération nationale des CAE madame
messieurs nous vous remercions d'avoir
bien sûr répondu à notre invitation nous
irons bien la complexité qu'il peut y
avoir à concilier à la fois les
impératifs de transition écologique avec
la protection de notre patrimoine et
pourtant il y a urgence à y parvenir
d'une part parce qu'il faut s'attendre à
une multiplication des travaux de
rénovation énergétique dans les années à
venir sous l'effet des dispositions de
la loi climat et résilience je suis sûr
qu'un certain nombre de collègues
interviendra sur ce point pour signaler
déjà des dossiers qui ont pu
arriver dans leur département respectifs
d'autre part parce que la réhabilitation
du bâtiment ancien apparaît d'un point
de vue écologique comme l'avenir de la
construction
Sabine Drexler avait
identifié dans son rapport plusieurs
leviers d'action dont je sais que vous
avez pu prendre connaissance ils
allaient de l'adaptation du cadre
réglementaire à l'amélioration de la
formation en passant par une meilleure
coordination interministérielle une plus
grande mobilisation des outils
disponibles ou encore le soutien à la
recherche et la remise à plat des aides
financières
nous sommes bien sûr impatient
d'entendre votre point de vue et vos
propositions pour faire en sorte
d'aboutir à une transition écologique
respectueuse de du patrimoine de notre
patrimoine avant de vous c'est des
successivement la parole pour une
intervention liminaire de 5 à 7 minutes
je me permets de vous rappeler que cette
audition fait l'objet d'une captation
vidéo retransmise en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat je vais donc vous
laisser la parole pour un propos
liminaire de 5 à 7 minutes et puis après
bien sûr nous aurons les uns et les
autres des questions à vous poser en
particulier notre rapporteur
semi-dire-exler commencera la première
série de questions je ne sais pas qui
commence il y a pas eu de tirage au sort
qui qui veut commencer à aller madame
peut-être
je vais vous demander d'appuyer sur le
bouton pour que vous m'entendez
correctement
donc merci de nous recevoir au nom de la
Fédération des CAE pour mémoire le
réseau des CAE peut-être n'est pas tout
à fait connu par vous tous donc nous
avons 92 implantations sur le territoire
national ces associations ont un statut
défini par la loi pour l'architecture de
1977 et qui ont pour mission de
conseiller former informer et
sensibiliser sur les thèmes de
l'architecture de l'urbanisme du paysage
et de l'environnement même si le P n'est
pas dans notre joli nom les
collectivités les particuliers les
administrations et les professionnels du
cadre de vie nous avons
je baisse le micro comme ça merci
les CAE ont une position spécifique qui
permet de réunir tous les acteurs
publics et privés pour inventer
collectivement des process efficaces
pour améliorer le partage de
connaissances
les enjeux et les objectifs liés aux
besoins d'une rénovation plus
conséquente la position d'un ce permet
de réunir les acteurs impliqués en
dehors de relation contractuelles
commerciales ou hiérarchique la proche
du sujet de la rénovation énergétique
par la valeur culturelle de
l'architecture peut permettre de
mobiliser les acteurs au-delà des
professionnels de la construction
la transversalité nécessaire à la bonne
mise en place d'un programme ambitieux
de rénovation du bâti ancien a besoin
d'un espace d'interaction stable et
pérenne comme les CdTe les communautés
départementales de la transition
énergétique sont devenus des points de
repère et des changes
pluridisciplinaires pour les acteurs
publics et privés de la transition
énergétique un nouvel espace peut
contribuer à la facilité le changement
des clés de lecture de tous les acteurs
impliqués
dans l'émission fondamentale des c.a.e
la sensibilisation l'information et la
formation les c.io contribuent déjà à
quelques éléments du sujet que vous
abordez par exemple rapidement le
sérieux 76 a publié un travail nommé la
réhabilitation architecturale et
thermique en ciblant ces sujets le CAE
78 a mené un travail sur l'impact
architectural de la rénovation
énergétique sur toutes les typologies
pas exclusivement le bâti ancien
l'Observatoire des cieux d'Île-de-France
pour la qualité architecturale du
logement a fait deux séminaires autour
de la rénovation énergétique du bâti
existant ou une part de bâti anciens
était bien représentée c'est en
partenariat avec la DRAC
le CIO 78 a fait un travail sur le rôle
de l'architecte dans la rénovation
puisque vous savez qu'il n'y a pas
d'obligation à ce recours notre CAE le
CEE 77 travail en partenariat avec
l'Union des architectes du département
et on organise des formations pour ces
acteurs du secteur privé notamment avec
des bureaux d'études comme Pouget qui
est un des acteurs historiques de la
connaissance thermique de nos
constructions essentiellement basées sur
la construction neuve autrefois et puis
nous avons aussi avec le ce 91 menait
une instrumentation sur la rénovation
pour amélioration énergétique d'un petit
immeuble 18e 19e dans un périmètre des
abords à Brunoy avec une rénovation en
béton de chanvre à l'intérieur du
bâtiment donc une instrumentation menée
par le Serein qui permet d'avoir des
pauses de sondes un examen sur deux ans
pour mesurer les données
ygrométriques et du bâtiment et chercher
à démontrer la pertinence du béton de
chanvre notamment donc c'est un appui à
la connaissance
les ciao représentent une ingénierie de
proximité puisque pour engager et
influencer les bonnes évolutions dans le
marché de la rénovation et un usage sans
regret des aides publiques les c.e sont
des conseillers
identifiés et pérennes je me permets
d'insister sur cela parce que de
nombreuses décisions d'élus de
nombreuses décisions d'acteurs ont
besoin d'avoir un référent qui dure
qu'il retrouve facilement les missions
auprès des communes pour répondre à
leurs impératifs de diminution de
factures offrent de nombreuses
opportunités pour déployer des projets
de rénovation pertinents vis-à-vis des
modes constructifs créatifs vis-à-vis
des rôles renouvelés des équipements
publics et exemplaires pour la
mobilisation de choix techniques sobre
et durable donc faire de bons exemples
en quelque sorte
à travers la diversité d'échelle des
communes enseignement nous avons 507
communes et tous les départements de
Seine-et-Marne de France ont cette
diversité d'échelle il est possible de
rencontrer une grande diversité
typologies bâtie qui peuvent devenir des
exemples inspirants pour tous les
citoyens concernés par des rénovations à
engager donc insister sur le fait que
au-delà du tiers de logement que
représente le bâti ancien on a tout le
patrimoine public qui est concerné et
qui sert qui devrait servir
d'exemplarité
la contribution à l'identification des
spécificités du bâti ancien puisque
c'est l'enjeu essentiel de nos
réflexions s'il bâtit ancien représente
seulement 30% des logements actuels y
constituent toute la structure l'âme de
nos centres-villes de nos coeurs de
bourg et de nos villages les maires les
salles des fêtes les écoles sont des
représentants fondamentaux de nos lieux
de vie
toutes les politiques actuelles d'arrêt
de l'étalement urbain de lutte contre
les îlots de chaleur de redynamisation
du commerce de proximité rencontre le
bâti ancien des milliers de fermes de
grange peuvent devenir de beaux et bons
logements seulement s'ils sont rénovés
avec intelligence et discernement la
densification des tissus urbains
existants questionnent la conservation
l'extension la surélévation du bâti
ancien la place des arbres existants
dans les îlots anciens doivent
s'examiner dans tout projet
densification
l'insertion du bâti 9 dans un îlot
ancien pour financer la rénovation du
bâti ancien doit se gérer avec attention
pour trouver des volumes compatibles
avec le respect des tissus urbains
historiques cette vue large n'est
maîtrisée que par des architectes
quand les architectes des bâtiments de
France sont absents d'un secteur seuls
les architectes conseils des c.a.e ou
ceux des mairies peuvent argumenter les
arbitrages et il y a des secteurs où il
n'y a pas
l'enjeu d'intérêt public la rénovation
du bâti ancien n'est pas qu'une affaire
de propriétaire qui ne peuvent plus
louer un bien non rénovés ou mal
entretenu pendant des décennies
la rénovation du bâti ancien est vitale
pour accompagner les bouleversements
sociétaux que va engendrer la transition
économique et écologique
si la rénovation du bâti ancien détruit
le patrimoine que la France assume
maintenir c'est notre place dans
l'histoire urbaine de notre époque que
nous détruisons
si nous sommes si fiers d'être la
première destination touristique du
monde c'est grâce au bâti anciens des
places de marché des ruelles médiévales
et c'est grâce au mur à pierrevue c'est
pas seulement pour les plages et les
jolis montagnes pour mobiliser les
propriétaires il faut sans doute étendre
les moyens pertinents des prêts
hypothécaires pour avancer les fonds qui
ne sont mesurés et perçues que lors des
mutations et qui concerne une toute
petite part de la population pour le
moment il faut engager des inventaires
des typologies bâties dans tous les
secteurs anciens des PLU et assigner des
règles de rénovation cela étant le code
de l'urbanisme s'exprime et formule les
règles des PLU sur l'aspect extérieur
des constructions donc on voit bien
qu'il y a une interaction à trouver avec
des enjeux notamment par la rénovation
intérieure et l'isolation intérieure
il faut fixer des minimums de
compétences cette terminologie est pas
géniale mais j'ai pas trouvé mieux pour
les accompagnateurs rénovs il nous
semble qu'il faut faire attention à
confier un commercial reconverti en
accompagnateur les propriétaires motivés
c'est ce qui s'augmente actuellement on
a des gens qui étaient je ne sais pas
moi assistante maternelle et petit
parents engagement veulent devenir
accompagnateur rénov c'est chouette mais
ça pose des questions il faut bâtir une
ingénierie aidé pour compenser la non
rentabilité des missions de maîtrise
d'oeuvre de rénovation faut être lucide
si le marché a été rentable il serait
pris par les prestataires en vigueur
aujourd'hui les grands bureaux d'études
aident les diagnostics des très grandes
villes quand on a des milliers de mètres
carrés de patrimoine à rénover
il faut encourager toutes les mesures
d'amélioration énergétique du bâti
ancien dans le cadre d'une mise à jour
globale des services rendus par le bâti
ancien sans chercher seulement à
atteindre les performances techniques du
bâti récent il faut abandonner cette
comparaison sans doute c'est à faire
entre nous avant de le faire comprendre
à l'extérieur le bâti ancien constitue
une valeur qui dépasse toute comparaison
avec ce que nous avons construit depuis
la Seconde Guerre mondiale presque tous
les Français et nos visiteurs aiment la
France pour ce dont nous avons
hérité
l'économie des ressources l'intelligence
bioclimatique la diversité
architecturale du bâti ancien sont les
fondements de notre culture
urbaine européenne il me semble qu'on
peut en parler à cette échelle depuis la
Seconde Guerre mondiale l'économie du
bâtiment est structurée autour de la
construction neuve toutes les grandes
entreprises du bâtiment sont devenues
internationales grâce à la rentabilité
du bâti neuf
pendant des décennies on a accepté le
regard économique à court terme qui
préfèrent démolir que rénover vous
l'avez tous entendu non non mettez-moi
ça par terre ça sera plus efficace
nous devons accompagner ce virage très
serré pour trouver une économie
nationale de la rénovation fondée sur
l'économie des ressources et la
réduction des déchets nous devons sortir
le bâti ancien de l'insalubrité de
l'inadaptation du désamour pour
conserver une stabilité culturelle
essentielle dans nos perspectives de
grands bouleversements c'est vraiment ce
que j'aimerais partager avec vous c'est
ce point de référence on ne peut pas le
regarder que comme j'habite et ça me
coûte cher c'est on habite tous le bâti
ancien nous devons inventer une nouvelle
temporalité pour rénerver soit des sites
occupés soit en hébergeant
provisoirement les propriétaires
occupants et les locataires
on peut un minimum encourager très
fortement pour ne pas dire en
obligatoire parce que c'est peut-être
pas très judicieux
les bâtiments qui sont vides lorsqu'ils
sont en vente à chaque fois qu'on vend
un bien immobilier il est vide quelques
mois compte tenu des procédures le
réinvestissement dans le bâti ancien
amorti depuis des décennies doit nous
mobiliser au-delà de son apparente
inadaptation thermique c'est notre cadre
de vie qui doit être réinvesti
si cela vous convient j'ai cru merci
madame je vais passer la parole à
Monsieur Sénéchal
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président écoutez
peut-être je vais je vais commencer en
disant que je souscris
voilà que je souscris pleinement aux
propos qui viennent d'être qui viennent
d'être dit et qui pose je pense le sujet
de manière de manière voilà demain de
manière très claire et très et très
stratégique voilà moi je de part de par
ma position
comme comme praticien dans les
départements vous vous nous connaissez
voilà nous sommes comme architecte des
Bâtiments de France donc agent du
ministère de la Culture nous sommes en
poste en département et nous travaillons
avec tous les élus des communes des
communes surtout des communes rurales
dans les territoires effectivement où on
constate des difficultés et des manques
d'ingénierie ce que je le premier point
voilà le premier point que je voulais
partager avec vous c'est
la question cette question de la
rénovation énergétique du bâti interroge
de manière plus générale vous l'avez dit
la question du logement et la question
de la ville on l'a vu
on passe de crise en crise
après la crise des gilets jaunes qui a
questionné la question du périurbain et
de comment on habite son quartier donc
la question de la ville on a eu la crise
du covid qui a questionné la question
enfin qui a posé la question du logement
voilà de la qualité du logement et on
s'est rendu compte que beaucoup de nos
concitoyens
voilà avaient un déficit de de vie dans
leur dans leur propre logement et
aujourd'hui on est percuté par la crise
énergétique qui vient poser la question
de la rénovation du bâti du bâti ancien
et on n'oubliera pas évidemment les
questions de zéro artificialisation qui
comme cela a été dit également
nous nous impose et à juste titre parce
que nous nous appelons ce sujet là de
nos vœux depuis depuis des années mais
impose le réinvestissement des centres
anciens du bâti ancien du déjà là voilà
on pourrait également parler de la crise
actuelle disons du conflit actuel qui
pose percute la question de comment on
construit de comment on fait les travaux
et on va dire du coup énergétique de la
construction donc on sait que il
représente un quart si je dis pas de
bêtises de la du coup énergétique
globale consommée et qui doit être qui
doit être réduit voilà et qui et qui
pour le coup questionne questionne la
les processus les habitudes et par voie
de conséquence les normes voilà donc
premier point la question la rénovation
énergétique du bâti doit questionner la
question du logement et de
l'amélioration du logement dans son
intégralité je pense que là c'est un
point important
et vous verrez où je veux en venir le
second point et que la rénovation
énergétique
rénovation du patrimoine la conservation
la préservation la mise en valeur du
patrimoine qui est
projets de l'architecte des bâtiments de
France sur les sur les sur les sur les
territoires
comment cette cette question là elle
alors d'abord je reviendrai sur un point
effectivement vous avez dit les
architectes des bâtiments de France ne
sont pas partout voilà effectivement
nous sommes sur 6% du territoire vous le
savez c'est très peu national du
territoire national 6% du territoire
national voilà c'est très peu mais ça
veut dire une chose ça veut dire que
quand on parle de rénovation énergétique
du bâti seul une part finalement
comment
probablement insuffisante du bâti et
concerné par
les lois et les textes du Code du
patrimoine en particulier qui vont nous
aider à avoir un regard sur cette
question de la préservation du du bâti
et de la même manière
hormis quand on a des cier hormis quand
on a des ingénieries dans les
collectivités suffisamment constituées
mais on sait que c'est souvent rares
surtout dans les territoires ruraux
finalement les élus que vous que vous
êtes les les professionnels se
retrouvent sans conseil sans
s'ingénierie de conseil pour porter ces
sujets là voilà donc c'est également un
point important qu'il faut avoir en tête
parce que je vais revenir mais enfin
vous nous y reviendront dans la
discussion mais la rénovation
énergétique du bâti ou l'amélioration de
l'habitat et de la ville
c'est une question qui doit qui doit
être vu dans le cas d'une chaîne globale
c'est-à-dire c'est un maître d'ouvrage
un concepteur on dit souvent qu'il y a
pas de bons projets sont bons maître
d'ouvrage voilà donc c'est un maître
d'ouvrage un concepteur mais qui bien
souvent n'est pas architecte c'est un
vrai sujet c'est ce sont des équipes
d'ING
la profession de de technicien n'est pas
réglementé en France et quand on se pose
la question sur nos territoires de
connaître les termiticiens qui ont des
compétences ou qui ont plutôt une
appétence en matière de bâti ancien et
on se rend compte que c'est que ce sont
des compétences rares très rares voilà
dans le Finistère où j'exerce j'en ai
identifié un en nouvelle-aquitaine des
confrères architectes sont désespérés
parce que leur thermiciens spécialiste a
pris sa retraite et que ils n'ont pas
trouvé la relève voilà donc on a un vrai
un vrai sujet de ce point de vue là on a
mais c'est une chaîne qui continue aussi
en amont également j'ai oublié
effectivement les conseiller ma prime
rénove les conseillers voilà qui ne sont
pas toujours formés vous l'avez dit je
reviens pas dessus et puis on a
également
quand on continue la chaîne
les artisans voilà et là on a un vrai
sujet alors vous savez que c'est un fait
partie de nos missions ministère de la
culture et des échecs des bâtiments de
France et si nous nous battons pour pour
préserver des mises en oeuvre
traditionnelles des enduits anciens des
fenêtres en bois faites sur mesure c'est
d'une part pour préserver ou pour
conserver un aspect
à notre patrimoine mais c'est aussi pour
conserver des savoir-faire or ces avoir
faire là on le constate dans nos
territoires ont disparu ou en tout cas
sont très difficiles
et ce sont ces entreprises et ses
savoir-faire là qui nous permettent et
qui vont nous permettre demain de faire
une rénovation massive parce que c'est
quand même ça l'enjeu du patrimoine
ancien voilà et c'était là le troisième
point sur lequel je voulais voilà
rapidement parce que on a dit 5 minutes
arrivé
on a dit et je pense qu'il faut le
redire
aujourd'hui tout le process tout le
processus est tourné vers des normes qui
sont des normes pensées pour le 9 or le
bâtiment ancien a d'autres qualités se
comportent différemment alors on
commence à l'entendre certains
organismes d'aiment le crébin voilà
travail sur ces sujets là et le fond
très bien mais néanmoins nos normes et
nos systèmes d'aide
financiers sont tous tournés à
destination du neuf voilà et là nous
avons voilà nous avons je pense un sujet
à interroger parce que
il ne faudrait pas et puis je terminerai
là-dessus sur deux idées un petit peu un
petit peu caricaturales mais on pourrait
y revenir on pourra revenir dessus la
première c'est que nous nous constatons
sur le terrain que par mes connaissances
80% du budget des gens si on parle
d'immeubles ou de logement individuels
et consacré pour résoudre 20-25% du
problème
donc ça ça doit nous interroger
d'une part et puis d'autre part que
certains architectes ont un petit peu
d'âge ou d'expérience comme comme moi
par exemple ont pu travailler dans une
autre vie
à faire de la rénovation du bâti voilà
dans les années 80-90 on a eu des
grandes campagnes vous le savez de
l'amélioration de l'habitat qui était
portée par les bactéries et puis par
d'autres organismes publics que constate
les Coast les bailleurs sociaux
aujourd'hui discussion est très
fréquemment qui est d'ailleurs sociaux
c'est que par manque d'adaptation et
d'adéquation des travaux que nous avons
mis en oeuvre dans les années 80-90 pour
l'amélioration du bâti tous ces
immeubles là enfin toutes ces tous ces
travaux faits en centre ancien sont à
reprendre sont à revoir et parfois ont
même dégradé considérablement l'état
sanitaire et là et la qualité de vie
dans ces dans ces bâtiments donc faisons
attention c'est mon message que je
résume faisons attention de bien
consacrer l'argent au bon endroit et de
faire en sorte que tout cet argent parce
que il y en a beaucoup qui sera consacré
à la rénovation énergétique du bâti ne
soit pas délétère et ne soit pas
contre-productif pour nos habitations
dans dans les 30 ou dans les 40 années à
venir voilà je vous remercie merci je
passe maintenant la parole à françois de
Mazières
oui merci monsieur le président
d'abord je voulais signaler la qualité
de l'examen du dossier qui nous a été
remis dans le cadre du projet loi de
finances pour 2023 je crois que vraiment
les sénateurs sénatrices et sénateurs
ont remarqué un travail et je tiens à
souligner il y a beaucoup de
propositions dedans les deux
interventions précédentes ont été
extrêmement intéressantes moi je
voudrais résumer mon propos en deux axes
le premier c'est qu'il y a un vrai
risque il y a un risque un peu de la
France j'ai exagère sans doute en le
disant mais de la France moche qu'est-ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que nous
sommes dans un risque de banalisation et
c'est vrai que comme on veut aller vite
parce qu'il y a une urgence climatique
on a tendance effectivement à faire
partout la même chose parce que
l'isolation doit se faire par
l'extérieur
parce que l'isolation empruntent
toujours les mêmes méthodes aujourd'hui
or on sait que le charme de la France
c'est aussi ce patrimoine ses
spécialités ces spécificités locales le
fait que effectivement les bonnets
nature sur les bâtiments donne de
l'élégance et ça il y a un risque de
disparition
quand on dit conférence ensuite
l'isolation par l'intérieur c'est
effectivement possible mais là encore
parfois on est amenés à détruire des
éléments de patrimoine donc il y a un
vrai risque et je le vois très
concrètement parce que vous m'avez
demandé d'essayer de donner des exemples
concrets je suis président d'une
intercommunalité je faisais le taux
d'une commune je sais pas cité et dans
l'urgence car il est urgence il faut
aussi qu'on fasse du logement cette
commune est notamment une commune qui a
encore carencé donc le maire fait des
efforts importants et on en arrive à
offrir des bâtiments intéressants
notamment des bâtiments de meulière par
exemple sont typiques et à une
banalisation assez terrifiante il faut
bien dire de notre environnement donc il
y a un vrai risque il faut pas le nier
et je tiens tout de même à souligner
votre travail le travail de sommeil
parce que il faut le dire il faut le
dire les
âges sociaux du G8 d'ailleurs on fait
une communication très intéressante en
signant un papier en novembre dernier au
moment où justement où il fallait un peu
réagir sur la loi de 2021 qui est
importante mais qui présente un certain
nombre de risques par rapport au
patrimoine et ces associations ont de
façon unanime dit attention
nourrissons de mettre en péril notre
patrimoine
et je crois que il y a vraiment
aujourd'hui un risque qui n'est aussi
d'une incompréhension c'est à dire que
toute repose aussi aujourd'hui sur le
diagnostic performance énergétique le
célèbre des PE et quand on voit la mise
en œuvre du DPE on s'aperçoit sur le
terrain qu'il y a parfois des gens pas
tout à fait qualifiés et qui en tout cas
ne connaissent absolument pas la
question du patrimoine vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure on traite de la même
façon un bâtiment ancien que un bâtiment
qui indice ou 20 ans est-ce que
souligner les associations patrimoine
c'est que le patrimoine avant 48 n'a
strictement rien à voir j'y reviendrai
parce que c'est même un atout par
rapport à la question environnementale
donc là on sent que il y a une
accélération de la législation une
accumulation il faut bien dire de loin
qui fait que plus personne n'y comprend
rien je peux vous dire puisqu'on me
demander des exemples précis dans mon
service et pourtant on est une ville
patrimoniale j'ai des services qui sont
très compétents mais c'est un peu
difficile à suivre à tel point que dans
ma ville les personnes propriétaires de
logement anciens se disaient il faut
qu'on vende en catastrophe après la loi
2021 il y a eu un moment de panique
parce qu'on se disait on va plus pouvoir
louer notre appartement à partir de 2025
ou 2028 suivant aussi c'est Angers ou en
F et il y a eu vraiment un moment de
panique on a même pas pris connaissance
qu'il y avait eu le message culture
féminin les choses regardent les choses
il y a eu un décret le 8 avril mais
personne n'en a connaissance il faut
être clair or ce décret du 8 avril
permet dans une de versa comme
Versailles d'être assez rassuré parce
que comme nous sommes dans un secteur
très protégé effectivement les règles
peuvent être assouplies et donc il n'y a
pas cet obligation pour la location
d'ici 2025-2028 mais personne n'est au
courant de même récemment le misère a
communiqué sur le fait que l'on pouvait
assouplir la règle sur le photovoltaïque
le photovoltaïque c'est un sujet parce
que aujourd'hui et je viens à un point
essentiel c'est que malheureusement vous
l'avez souligné ce président les
abeilles font un travail remarquables
courageux mais aujourd'hui ils n'en
peuvent plus je prends le cas de la
direction demandé partement il doit
paraf faire
4000 avis par an
comment voulez-vous qu'il fasse c'est
pas sérieux et surtout ça ne permet pas
si vous voulez de faire
ce suivi intelligent pour la rénovation
parce que si on veut faire un CV
intelligent il faut pouvoir dialoguer il
faut prendre du temps donc on a aussi un
véritable problème de suivi aujourd'hui
même quand il existe un dispositif de
protection et comme vous le disiez
monsieur président en plus c'est 6% de
territoire quant au cya très bonne idée
mais je me permets de dire que les CAE
malheureusement
voilà parfois souffre aussi le problème
d'effectif et que sont très inégaux de
département un département donc c'est ça
la réalité que nous vivons en tant qu'
élu et puis je voudrais souligner un
point qui me paraît vraiment très
préoccupant c'est qu'aujourd'hui l'État
est confronté à des logiques
contradictoires à l'État devient un peu
schizophrénique c'est à dire que dans ma
ville qui est une patrimoniale
aujourd'hui quand l'état avancé bien or
beaucoup sont du domaine du patrimoine
ils vont le plus cher possible
à tel point que je suis interdit de
participer dans les jurys sur les
projets ce qui est aberrant aberrant
baissé ce que je vis et j'ai des
exemples très concrets très précis de
ces deux dernières années on en arrive à
vendre un bien qui fait l'objet d'un
intérêt architectural parce que bâtiment
de rouge Pitts un prix extrêmement élevé
en interdisant aux gens de venir me voir
avant des promoteurs pour qu'on fasse
monter le prix c'est ça que l'on vit
donc il y a tout de même aussi des
petites contradictions qu'il faut si on
veut vraiment collectivement protéger le
patrimoine et attention
c'est très bien de vouloir renflouer les
caisses et étages en si ravi mais
commençons tout de même à établir un
vrai dialogue sur une ville d'histoire
donc on est à un moment j'ai décrit les
risques mais je voulais dans une
deuxième partie vous dire que pour moi
je l'ai signé dans des articles c'est
pourtant une opportunité extraordinaire
qui se présente à nous c'est une
opportunité parce que si l'on réfléchit
bien le patrimoine c'est un élément pour
au contraire
renforcer la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique car beaucoup de
patrimoine anciens sont naturellement
conçus pour être des bâtiments qui sont
intelligents par rapport au climat et ça
on oublie le dire on oublie de dire
aussi que la pire des façons aujourd'hui
par rapport à la création des gaz à
effet de serre on le sait c'est la
construction et on n'est pas assez en
valeur et là aussi nous sommes dans des
contradictions là une loi récente et
essentielle qui est maintenant vous le
savez on estime quand on construit un
bâtiment ce n'est plus la RT qui était
une règlementation thermique on est sur
la re
règlementale qui est un grand acquis ça
veut dire quoi que sur 50 ans de vie
moyenne de 50 ans un bâtiment on va
estimer la création gaz à effet de serre
or la création des gaz à effet c'est
entre 7 et 90% sur la totalité de cette
création gaz à effet de serre sur 50
années de vie c'est au moment de la
création du bâtiment et ça on l'intègre
pas quand on passe au patrimoine
c'est-à-dire que le patrimoine a un
atout naturel
si on pense globalement au problème de
l'environnement et on ne le dit pas et
comme le vous le disait tout à l'heure
on raisonne quasiment la même chose en
temps ce qui fait que les architectes
que j'ai bien entendu quand je présidais
à citer architecte au patrimoine qui ont
beaucoup évolué aujourd'hui la président
de l'or des architectes Christine
Leconte a fait un livre récemment pour
dire que il fallait transformer le
logiciel parce qu'il fallait bien sûr
qu'on soit bâtiment neuf mais il fallait
aussi surtout aujourd'hui apprendre à
rénover et là cette révolution
intellectuelle elle est fondamentale et
donc défend le patrimoine quelque part
c'est aussi s'insérer dans une logique
de protection de l'environnement et on
le dit pas assez alors à partir de ce
moment là je trouve qu'il y a une
opportunité qu'on ne saisit pas assez et
cette opportunité elle veut dire que il
va falloir que l'on prenne un certain
nombre de mesures vous les avez très
bien lissés dans votre porte d'abord il
faut renforcer la
c'est clair dans les écoles
d'architecture on ne parle quasiment pas
aujourd'hui de la question du patrimoine
ou très peu on commence un peu plus
certaines écoles l'école de ma ville on
en parle mais elle est un peu
particulière ça fait partie de
l'histoire architecture de l'école
architecture de Versailles mais beaucoup
ont fait très peu et la rénovation est
un élément qu'il faut mettre en avant
dans la formation des architectes je
pense aussi que il faut renforcer la
recherche sur les nouveaux matériaux
beaucoup de choses a été dit en ce
domaine en 2011 il y avait eu une étude
qui menée aussi avec les associations
patrimoine parce que je parlerai le rôle
on n'a pas encore évoqué mais c'est
essentiel elles ont un rôle capital
justement pour pouvoir répondre au
problème aujourd'hui de manque
d'effectif dans certains services
et puis je crois qu'il faut aussi
réfléchir à transformer la projet des PE
si c'est un c'est du diagnostic qui fait
dans le patrimoine il faut que ce soit
des gens qui soient conscient que c'est
différent que dans un bâtiment neuf il
faut peut-être des spécialistes des PEP
patrimoine ça me paraît aujourd'hui une
très utile en plus il y en a incroyable
complexité du système des aides un
effort a été fait avec la prime rénove
mais ça reste tout même je l'ai expliqué
tout à l'heure j'avais un cas concret ça
reste un peu flou et donc il faudrait un
peu renforcer cette communication
responsabiliser et collectivités locales
me paraît aussi essentielle parce que au
fond c'est elle qui vont avoir un
travail à faire il y a 400 millions de
mètres carrés de bâtiments publics et
les trois quarts sont des bâtiments des
collectivités locales donc il va falloir
aider les collectivités locales alors il
y a la mise en place récemment d'un
système de tiers financière qui a été
adopté à l'Assemblée nationale c'est un
système certes intéressant mais
attention on vient de sortir des
empreintes toxiques
garantir finalement le remboursement sur
des améliorations énergétiques on voit
bien que les prix l'énergie fluctue
beaucoup donc parfois cette garantie
elle va être compliquée à mettre en
place il faut être donc les directs
collectivités et certainement pour du
point de vue des collectivités une chose
plus efficace on peut aussi mettre en
place tous les dispositifs qui existe
par exemple vous avez aujourd'hui
certaines villes dans le cas de la loi
SRU doivent des pénalités pourquoi pas
utiliser aussi ces pénalités pour
financer de la rénovation thermique et
notamment dans le cas du patrimoine
ancien
je pense aussi au phénomène peréquation
la péricquation est un siège attire la
tension des
sénatrices et c'est l'auteur parce que
pour moi je l'ai déjà dit quand j'étais
moi-même député la péréquation qui se
renouvelle d'un année avec le même
montant c'est quelque chose de très
pervers la péréquation prend sous une
commune pour donner soit notre commune
on ne sait pas ce qu'on fait l'autre
commune il y a aucun rapport sur ce
qu'on fait l'autre commune alors que la
péréquation pourrait devenir un
instrument intelligent et que les
communes qui font des efforts et qui
sont opérés à la baisse on pourrait dire
ah ben vous faites des gros efforts sur
par exemple un investissement
patrimonial on le prend en compte qu'on
est une péréquation qui deviennent
intelligente ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui puisque chaque année on
remet à Versailles ces 8 points la poche
chaque année qu'on nous envole comme ça
systématiquement
alors que il y a tout même à prendre en
compte un contexte on a perdu l'année
dernière au profit du château de
Versailles les recettes de la Plaza
l'équivalent 6 points d'impôts annuels
aucune compensation rien la péricquation
pour intégrer voilà et donc si on pense
par rapport à la vie des collectivités
locales il y a des moyens qui existent
enfin je voudrais dire que pour arriver
à tous ces défis relever tous ces défis
encore beaucoup d'exemples qu'on
pourrait donner mais
les associations sont importantes
vous l'avez dit j'étais directeur
général la fondation de patrimoine je
trouve la fondation de patrimoine a fait
un travail c'est remarquable ces
dernières années donc j'y suis plus
pas du tout pro domo je constate
seulement ce qu'ils ont fait
c'est vrai que le label du patrimoine le
bal la Fondation patrimoine est un outil
très intéressant est-ce qu'on ne
pourrait pas utiliser aussi
en les tendons peut-être cela belle
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas l'utiliser
pour faciliter les rénovations voilà un
levier intéressant par rapport aux
propriétaires privées de bâtiments
anciens en plus
l'association du G7 G8 ça a évolué de
ces grandes associations je pense par
exemple maison paysanne aussi qui ont
une vraie une vraie culture comment on
peut utiliser les techniques anciennes
pour faire l'isolation tout ceci est
très intéressant il faut s'appuyer sur
ces associations aussi pour permettre
d'avoir une meilleure approche de cette
question la rénovation énergétique et
comme je dis et à la fois un risque et
c'est là où le mot défi était très bien
trouvé dans votre rapport c'est à la
fois un risque mais c'est aussi si on
l'exo soit bien une opportunité
merci j'ai donné la parole maintenant un
Boris Ravignon qui nous disent comment à
travers les financements l'Agence
nationale de la transition écologique
peut parvenir à cet équilibre entre
rénovation thermique et préservation du
bâti oui alors en reprenant peut-être
monsieur brillance vous me permettez
mesdames messieurs
ce qu'est aujourd'hui l'ADEME et comment
comment l'intervient donc il s'agit de
l'Agence nationale de la transition
écologique et je vous remercie de
retenir de nouveaux câble puisque
effectivement on était haute
historiquement agence de l'environnement
et de la maîtrise de l'énergie et je
crois que la contribution que nous
apportons effectivement se tourne vers
la réalisation de cette transition
écologique dans un certain nombre de ces
de ces domaines et les fonds principaux
dont dispose l'ADEME et que connaissent
bien sûr ici les sénateurs mais les élus
locaux plus plus également tourne autour
de développement de la chaleur
renouvelable de dispositifs semi
circulaire et effectivement de
l'accompagnement de des mutations de
notre parc de logement puisque c'est
l'un des très grands enjeux
effectivement écologique de notre pays
pour simplement rappeler des chiffres je
crois nous avons tous à peu près bien en
tête pour atteindre la neutralité
carbone à l'horizon 2050 il nous faut
arriver à mener 90% du parc de logement
donc des 30 millions de logements que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui à un niveau
de consommation équivalent à celle du
BBC on a aujourd'hui une consommation
qui est de l'ordre de 200 kWh par mètre
carré par an en moyenne dans le parc de
logements français et on doit descendre
à 80 sur 90% du parc donc c'est c'est
dire l'ampleur du travail qui qui
convient d'accomplir pour que le secteur
du de l'habitat
prennent sa part simplement dans dans
cette neutralité carbone que nous
envisageons et que nous devons envisager
sans quoi et bien ensuite on sait que
les hausses de température
qui en résulterait serait absolument
dramatique pour pour l'humanité donc on
a contribution de l'habitat c'est cette
évolution là dans laquelle il y a
effectivement le parc de logement alors
même si on considère que puisque indiqué
90% du parc devait avoir à terme niveau
de
consommation énergétique équivalent au
BBC peut-être considéré que c'est les
10% restants seront seraient dans le
dans le dans le bâti ancien mais même en
considérant ça il va quand même falloir
que puisqu'on a un tiers de nos
logements qui se trouvent dans le bâti
ancien bien qu'on est entre 20 et 25% de
notre parc de logement d'aujourd'hui
donc autour de 7 millions de logements 7
millions 7 millions et demi de logements
qui connaissent cette évolution en
termes de consommation énergétique donc
c'est cette quelque chose c'est un enjeu
absolument considérable et c'est un
enjeu dans la réussite de vous décrire
les quelques grands chiffres qui sont
finalement un peu ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui
la planification écologique c'est
comment on atteint les objectifs sur
plusieurs décennies
je crois que c'est aussi et ça a été ça
a été rappelé ce bâti ancien une
nécessité sociale de de le faire évoluer
les gens qui vivent dans ce dans ce
tiers des logements on je crois les
mêmes droits à bénéficier des progrès de
en termes de consommation énergétique
que ceux qui vivent dans des logements
plus récents et je crois qu'il y aurait
là pour le coup je rejoins mon collègue
françois de Mazières un vrai danger de à
ce que le bâti ancien ne participe pas
une s'intègre pas dans la transition
écologique qu'il devienne finalement un
espace de déclassement parce qu'il
aurait des coûts de fonctionnement et
des coûts énergétiques très supérieurs
aux autres
on voit ce que des
logements loi 48 sans privés
d'investissement pendant des décennies
on finit par donner malheureusement
une forte concentration d'habitat à un
salut libre et la plupart du temps tout
à fait sordide donc on a un enjeu je
crois fondamental à
accompagner la transition écologique du
bâti existant à lui faire réaliser ses
progrès et pour pour les raisons
effectivement de cohérence dans le dans
le dans le mouvement qu'il nous convient
de réaliser
pour atteindre la neutralité carbone
pour protéger aussi et faire bénéficier
les habitants de ce bâti ancien des
progrès en termes de consommation ça
veut dire quand même moins d'argent
dépensé dans l'énergie c'est absolument
fondamental mais on a naturellement le
souhait et la nécessité de respecter les
caractéristiques de spati ancien et donc
l'agence
entre la dame aujourd'hui elle concentre
son travail vraiment encore sur des
phases que vous allez certainement
considérer comme des phases assez en
amont du sujet parce qu'on considère
nous qu'on a encore pas tout à fait
correctement documenté ce que le bâti
ancien ces habitat d'avant 48 qui a une
vraie diversité la différence et
pourquoi on a cette césure dans
l'après-guerre c'est parce que
considère à leur probablement
abusivement elle doit faire l'objet de
discussions je veux pas rentrer dans des
dans des débats scientifiques trop
importants mais qu'avant et surtout
après on a une forme de standardisation
des modes de construction
une généralisation de d'un type de
construction qui qui
relève effectivement l'automatisation on
a une forme d'industrialisation en fait
de la construction qui
fait que des bâtiments différents points
du territoire et ont des
caractéristiques communes avant c'est au
contraire une très grande hétérogénéité
une très grande diversité ça a été
rappelé quelques exemples de François
Mazières et donc on a vraiment encore le
besoin de d'abord bien comprendre
ce que sont les caractéristiques d'un
certain nombre de bâtiment c'est pas la
même chose qu'on danse trop à trois sur
des bâtiments des maisons à colombages
ou si on est dans le dans le dans
l'Aubrac avec des maisons en pierre de
taille donc on a je crois vraiment la
nécessité de comprendre
cette diversité les caractéristiques
thermiques les caractéristiques
hygrohermiques effectivement la question
de la gestion de l'humidité est un sujet
essentiel semble-t-il par architecte moi
ni ingénieur mais dans ces dans ce bâti
ancien et puis les caractéristiques
architecturales qui qui effectivement
peuvent dans certains nombre de cas
François Mazières a raison être
favorable à l'isolation et sur favorable
un certain nombre d'objectifs que nous
pouvons poursuivre mais pour cela il
faut vraiment bien connaître l'habitat
dans sa diversité et aujourd'hui on a
tendance à considérer que ça n'est pas
encore le cas et que donc il est
difficile dans cette dans cette phase là
et c'est pour ça je confirme
qu'effectivement les normes dont l'ADEME
n'est pas l'auteur on contribue à
essayer de les mettre en oeuvre quand
elles existent mais les réglementations
énergétiques la revint 20 et bien elle
est applicable essentiellement ou neuf
c'est c'est effectivement sur la
construction neuve et on ne peut pas se
satisfaire une transition écologique qui
ne concernerait que le pourcent de
logement que nous créons chaque année
grâce à la construction par rapport aux
99% du stock existant donc on a vraiment
la nécessité de travailler
après sur la base de cette connaissance
de fine du bâti sur des guides de bonnes
pratiques sur des sur des procédés alors
effectivement
ça inclut et de la recherche sur dans
les matériaux mais il y a vraiment un
travail assez considérable de recherche
à réaliser sur la mise en oeuvre de ces
matériaux parce qu'elle est spécifique à
chacune et chacune des constructions il
y a une raison évidente à faire tout ça
c'est qu'il y a quand même une
protection aussi j'ai une que directeur
du patrimoine le rappellera il y a aussi
une protection qui s'applique au bâti
ancien
en matière de rénovation qui font que
l'isolation par l'extérieur par exemple
ça a été évoqué n'est possible que si
elle n'est pas en contradiction avec les
protections prévues
ça c'est une règle qu'on doit appliquer
partout et
le les traitements qu'on peut appliquer
aux différentes parois là aussi sont
soumises aux protections prévues par le
bâtiment et donc aujourd'hui il nous
faut sur ce bâtiment ancien vraiment
inventé pas d'autres mots parce que ça
n'existe pas elle dans la plupart des
cas inventé à la fois alors peut-être
des matériaux mais en tout cas la mise
en oeuvre de ces matériaux pour
améliorer les qualités énergétiques et
les qualités thermiques de du bâti
ancien en question donc on a nous
l'ADEME choisi de aujourd'hui de
soutenir ses nettement la recherche sur
ces sujets c'est là qu'on mobilise les
moyens qui nous sont confiés accompagner
la création de de label nouveau par
exemple et synergie patrimoine qui a
fait l'objet d'une expérimentation
pendant trois ans 2020 2021 et 2022 ont
testé avec cette idée de voir si d'abord
tout simplement le BBC dans le bâti
ancien est-ce que c'était possible
première conclusion d'une
expérimentation qui vient de se dérouler
c'est qu'on peut y parvenir mais que ça
suppose effectivement un travail
vraiment qui qui réconcilie les deux
dimensions que nous évoquons aujourd'hui
effectivement le
traitement l'amélioration thermique des
bâtiments et la protection du patrimoine
on ne peut pas sauf à avoir vraiment
commettre de poser de grands dommages au
bâti en question dissocier les deux il
faut vraiment arriver à trouver des gens
qui sont capables justement de de en
même temps rénover le patrimoine en
question et et le comme dans les règles
de l'art si je puis dire et lui faire
mettre d'améliorer ses performances
thermiques c'est possible on a on a des
exemples qui nous ont montré que c'était
que c'était atteignable comme objectif
simplement ça suppose une coordination
beaucoup plus forte et et
qui commence sur laquelle la base pour
laquelle
expérimentation va pouvoir produire un
certain nombre de guides et ensuite il y
aura effectivement un travail assez
considérable de formation de diffusion
de ces pratiques mais on est vraiment
sur de notre point de vue sur un sujet
ou on ne va pas pouvoir faire du
standardiser il va nous falloir
effectivement alors travailler par
typologie de bâti anciens et puis
ensuite pouvoir diffuser des règles de
bonne pratique comme on le comme on l'a
fait beaucoup plus grande échelle sur du
bâti plus récent avec d'autres d'autres
labels qui heureusement ce sont
développés et concernent aujourd'hui des
millions de logements donc voilà un peu
l'approche qui est la nôtre aujourd'hui
c'est c'est vraiment de continuer à
mettre l'accent sur la recherche de
cette conciliation parce que on est bien
conscient qu'on ne peut pas éviter
on ne doit pas d'ailleurs même éviter la
transition écologique dans le bâti
ancien mais qui ça fait l'objet ça doit
faire l'objet d'adaptation absolument
indispensable et propre à sa
préservation merci Jean-François Hébert
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs je suis très
heureux de intervenir à ces tables
rondes avec les intervenants qui sont
exprimés et qui m'ont beaucoup facilité
la tâche puisque ils ont déjà dit
beaucoup de choses mais comme acteurs de
terrain donc je vais reprendre quelques
éléments et peut-être me concentrer sur
des quelques axes qui sont dans le
rapport de Sabine d'exler et qui n'ont
pas été très développés à ce stade
simplement je voudrais dire que la prise
en compte de ce sujet ne date pas d'hier
ça fait déjà quelques années qu'on
travaille notamment avec les
associations qui évoquaient françois de
Mazières sur cette question de la
transition écologique du bâti ancien
mais il y a une actualité évidemment
beaucoup plus forte maintenant c'est
devenu une priorité du gouvernement et
c'est une priorité du ministère de la
Culture je tiens à commencer mon propos
en disant bien que la transition
écologique est une priorité de notre
ministère on aura bientôt une feuille de
route que on est en train de mettre au
point et la ministre en parlera dans les
semaines qui viennent
ça a été très bien dit aussi je crois à
la fois par Madame du Tertre et puis par
François la préservation du patrimoine
est écologique par essence ou vous-même
monsieur le Président l'avait dit et
vous en êtes tous conscience et c'est
cette préservation elle est écologique
par excellence puisque on conserve des
sols en conserve des ressources des
matériaux on protège des immeubles en
prothèses des objets mobiliers qu'on
transmet aux générations qui viennent
donc c'est vraiment par essence même
écologique moi je voudrais une fois
qu'on a dit ça bon au ministère on
travaille sur beaucoup beaucoup d'axes
sur sur ce sujet je vais simplement
reprendre quelques points qui ont été
évoqués notamment sur la formation mais
je vais me concentrer plutôt sur
l'interministérialité parce que c'est un
sujet qui qui nous est propre je dirais
si je reviens un tout petit peu sur la
formation et sans être trop long nous
travaillons sur la formation des
professionnels c'est un axe évidemment
très important ça a été dit on sait pas
tout aujourd'hui on progresse on
alors je corrige un tout petit peu le
propos de François sur les écoles
d'architecture elles sont maintenant
toutes toutes complètement engagée dans
cette affaire de transition écologique
tous les projets qui sortent des jeunes
étudiants de nos écoles ont une
dimension de transition écologique la
ministre vient de créer un prix il y a
deux jours sur ce sujet il y a un
mouvement extrêmement fort et puis je
redis ça m'étonne moi-même beaucoup en
tant que directeur de l'architecture 60
70 % des des projets d'architecture
aujourd'hui sont sur de la rénovation de
la réutilisation c'est sidérant de plus
en plus c'est majoritaire maintenant
c'est plus de la construction neuve donc
c'est extrêmement important c'est un
mouvement de fond dans notre pays qui
est très encourageant du point de vue
qui nous occupe voilà oui mais c'est un
mouvement qui démarre très très fort et
qui qui est là déjà donc je voulais
juste le signaler sur la formation
on reviendra là dessus après les profs
aussi s'y mettent tout le monde s'y met
mais bon c'est un début c'est un
mouvement je crois qu'il faut vraiment
en avoir conscience sur la formation
initiale bon je développe pas plus sur
la formation continue on fait des choses
avec l'école de Chaillot il y a eu un
énorme travail de la dernière au mois de
juin qui a associé les architectes du
patrimoine et puis le Centre d'études et
d'expertise sur les risques
l'environnement la mobilité
l'aménagement je le cite parce que c'est
le serema qui fait des choses
extrêmement importantes dans ce domaine
c'était c'était
extrêmement important parce que on a pu
mobiliser des professionnels et les
faire travailler sur
les matériaux isolants les filières
biologiques la question des fenêtres des
cas pratiques enfin c'est vraiment très
très concret on a lancé aussi où on va
lancer une formation en ligne avec le
serema qui va durer un mois je donne
juste les thèmes des 4 semaines qui vont
mobiliser tous les tous les
professionnels qui voudront bien
s'inscrire qui sont souvent des
architectes la dernières semaines sera
consacrée aux enjeux liés à la
réhabilitation énergétique responsable
du bâti ancien donc ça c'est des
approches générales ensuite ils
travailleront la deuxième semaine sur la
méthode à adopter pour concevoir un
projet de réhabilitation énergétique
responsable la troisième semaine c'est
les spécifices cités techniques là aussi
on a des champs à approfondir notamment
avec l'ADN et d'autres et puis la
quatrième ce seront des solutions
d'amélioration énergétique respectueuse
du patrimoine et techniquement adapté
sur les fenêtres sur les murs sur les
planchers on sait très bien lors de la
parler des façades mais on sait très
bien que
labellisation mais je voudrais me
concentrer sur la dimension politique de
qui nous occupe parce que c'est vraiment
cette dimension que le ministère doit
prendre en compte
dimension politique au sens de politique
publique évidemment on est tous
conscient que il faut réussir à
concilier et ça aussi été dit il y a des
exigences elles sont apparemment
contradictoires c'est évident on
poursuit des objectifs qui sont
différents si on veut pousser les
énergies renouvelables et si on veut
protéger le patrimoine mais la
conviction qui est la nôtre
c'est que on peut trouver des voies pour
concilier ces politiques publiques
indispensables au développement de notre
pays c'est possible et on a décidé
déjà avec Roselyne Bachelot à Forterie
avec Rima Abdoul Malak travailler avec
nos collègues de la transition
écologique transition énergétique et le
bon exemple que connaît par cœur que
vous connaissez par cœur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs ça a été
évidemment le projet de loi sur
l'accélération de la production des
énergies renouvelables qui nous a qui
vous a mobilisé j'y reviendrai mais qui
nous a mobilisé nous d'abord avec
l'intuition que si on parvenait à
dessiner des orientations pour le
terrain
en coordination avec nos collègues de la
transition écologique et énergétique ça
serait une manière d'éviter qu'on en
vienne à des mesures je dirais pardon je
l'ai qualifie comme ça parce que c'est
je suis responsable du patrimoine je
dirais presque démagogique qui serait
par exemple de supprimer la vie conforme
des ABS parce que c'est plus simple on
se passe de la vie de ces de ces
gardiens du patrimoine et comme ça on
fait ce qu'on veut on
installe des panneaux
photovoltaïques partout dans les centres
villes ils viennent de Chine et puis
deux trois ans après on a que nos yeux
pour pleurer parce qu'on a perdu notre
patrimoine après je fais pas un dessin
vous avez tous très bien défendu cette
cette vision
apocalyptique enfin en tout cas on s'est
opposé mais on a on a pensé que
travailler ensemble était la meilleure
des méthodes donc le ministère de la
Culture a préparé les éléments de
doctrine c'est pas facile doctrine c'est
un peu fort mais en tout cas des
orientations parce que c'est sur le
terrain que ça se que ça se met en
oeuvre simplement il faut des
orientations et ce que le ministère a
fait comme effort sur lui-même c'est de
dire on va pas rester braquer sur non il
y aura pas de panneaux photovoltaïques
dans les zones qui sont protégées par
les APL mais on va les accepter dans les
centres-villes simplement on va
organiser leur installation on dira non
à priori sur les monuments historiques
alors que certains élus étaient prêts à
le faire encore que il peut y avoir des
ajustements mais on va orienter
organiser l'insertion de ces panneaux
intelligemment dans les dans les centres
anciens et ça on a réussi à le faire
avec les deux autres collègues
ministériels et on le sait vous le savez
comme moi ça a été un mécanisme de
défense qui a permis de surmonter les
oppositions de certains par le menteur
qui était tenté par la suppression de la
vie conforme de l'ABF et ça nous a
permis de dire attendez on travaille de
manière intelligente laissons faire ces
choses on verra plus tard si si c'est
pas ça fonctionne pas
ça c'était le point que je voulais
évoquer ça a été et je tiens d'ailleurs
à remercier vous-même monsieur le
Président et l'ensemble de la commission
parce que vous avez été à l'appui du
ministère de la culture et du ministère
de la transition écologique dans cette
affaire et comme ça je l'entendais dire
derrière moi on n'est pas passé on n'est
pas passé bien loin d'une catastrophe
qui aurait été la réédition alors pardon
je parle toujours du point de vue du
ministère de la culture et de la
Direction générale des patrimoines un
peu comme l'entorse dans la loi Elan qui
autorise les mers en cas de patrimoine
insalubre de se passer de la vie
conforme alors aujourd'hui il y a pas
beaucoup d'exemples de ces de ces
entorses ça reste quand même une
préoccupation pour le patrimoine je
tiens à le dire devant la commission
donc merci beaucoup de votre soutien
demain aujourd'hui demain on continue
dans cette voie c'est ça que je voulais
vous dire de l'interministratérialité
parce que c'est la bonne voie de mon
point de vue on va travailler sur ça a
été dit sur le diagnostic de performance
énergétique il y a un énorme travail à
faire encore il est pas du tout abouti
on a encore des des
concertations à mener pour finalement
mieux diffuser la méthodologie du DPE
adaptée au patrimoine bâti on veut faire
évoluer les critères d'attribution des
dispositifs de soutien qui sont pas
adaptés ça a été un peu dit mais la
fameuse ma prime rénove
mérite un peu d'être revu pour que on
puisse l'adapter éviter des mesures trop
invasives et destructives du patrimoine
on veut capitaliser sur toutes les
données accumulées par toutes les
instances scientifiques comme le crébat
les associations professionnelles que
j'évoquais Lana BF évidemment et
traduire
des données en recommandation à nouveau
en direction du terrain pour que on
puisse encadrer l'action de l'État en ce
domaine il y a aussi un travail à
engager en qui est déjà engagé qui va
l'être au mois de mars d'ailleurs sur la
norme européenne alors pardon je la cite
sans connaître
sans doute des gens qui doivent mieux la
maîtriser que moi NFEN 16 883 qui est
intitulé principe directeur pour
l'amélioration de la performance
énergétique des bâtiments d'intérêt
patrimonial de juin 2017 il nous
apparaît important de la retravailler à
l'aune de ce que je vous ai dit et des
évolutions on a aussi un autre chantier
qui va nous occuper beaucoup et qui qui
n'est pas du tout anecdotique et
structurant j'ai parlé des combles mais
on a aussi un travail à faire sur les
menuiseries des fenêtres des monuments
historiques on constate en fait que
la conservation des menuiseries de
fenêtres d'intérêt patrimoniales et
remise en cause par les modalités de
d'attribution des subventions de la
rénovation économique il y a quelque
chose qui colle pas une incohérence des
politiques publiques évoquées François
tout à l'heure il faut qu'on corrige le
tir sur cette affaire on a travaillé
encore une fois avec nos collègues du
mpe là dessus on a travaillé avec avec
l'ADN évidemment on voudrait là aussi
réussir à donner des directives à nos
à nos échelons locaux que que sont les
ABS on voudrait travailler aussi avec
les entreprises des groupes en
entreprise spécialisés je pense
au GMH qui sont on a pas cité tout à
l'heure mais c'est très important aussi
de voir que dans ces sujets il y a ce
que peuvent faire les associations et à
ce que peut faire les professionnels
parce que ils ont intérêt eux à pousser
la modernisation l'innovation pour nous
proposer des matériaux innovants et on
sait bien qu'on n'est pas encore arrivé
au bout du compte mais les architectes
qui travaillent les entreprises doivent
travailler il faut mettre des fonds dans
l'innovation pour inventer de nouveaux
matériaux on veut aussi harmoniser les
les pratiques d'autorisation de travaux
les ça c'est un travail plus interne au
ministère et là aussi on veut développer
des formations donc on aura l'année
prochaine ah non cette année en 23
plusieurs journées de travail collectif
collaboratif sur les menuiseries
anciennes voilà je voulais juste vous
dire ça c'est un énorme travail qui est
engagé de l'interministérialité je pense
que c'est la voie de l'avenir merci je
ne doute pas que mes collègues vont
revenir sur certains de vos
interventions on va commencer les
premières questions avec celle de Sabine
Draxler
des crédits budgétaires merci monsieur
le Président alors je voudrais tout
d'abord vous remercier tous pour vos
présentations très riches très
éclairantes aussi et qui confirme
malheureusement les craintes que nous
avons nous-mêmes déjà pu exprimer au
sein de cette commission
alors que la loi climat est résilience
entre dans sa phase concrète nous
constatons en effet et avec et ferment
qu'elle n'a pas tenu compte comme il
aurait fallu du patrimoine bâti de notre
pays en particulier du petit patrimoine
non protégé souvent rural celui de nos
villages de nos hameau qui caractérisent
nos régions et attire chaque année des
millions de touristes c'est nul ici ne
conteste la nécessité de mener à bien le
chantier de la rénovation énergétique
nous déplorons tous qu'on est mis en
place des procédures qui vont causer
autant de dégâts que ce qu'elle vise à
prévenir je pense notamment et vous
l'aurez compris au DPE et à ces critères
en partie inadaptés au bâti présentant
un intérêt historique qui conjugué aux
ânes et aux spéculations foncières qu'il
va engendrer vont se révéler
catastrophique pour le patrimoine bâti
de notre pays
le bâti ancien qui représente on l'a dit
tout à l'heure un tiers du parc
habitable concerné par la loi nécessite
certes des travaux mais ceci doivent
être réalisés dans le respect de son
implantation de ses propriétés
hydrothermiques et d'inertie faute de
quoi il le condamne comme c'est déjà le
cas chez moi en Alsace ou des normes
d'isolation préconisées sans nuance
représente de véritables aubaines pour
les professionnels de l'isolation qui
n'hésitent pas à étouffer des pans de
bois sous du polystyrène
et parce qu'un malheur n'arrive jamais
seul les propriétaires bailleurs qui
voudront continuer à louer leurs biens
se retrouvent aujourd'hui contraint de
suivre des préconisations inadaptées ou
de les délaisser s'ils ne sont pas en
mesure de réaliser les travaux une
aubaine cette fois pour les
constructeurs qui rachètent au prix du
terrain ces maisons inhabitées et
dégradé faute de pouvoir être loué mais
en qui finiront démolir remplacés par
des constructions neuves dans le cadre
de la mise en œuvre du zan
alors que celui-ci pourrait être une
opportunité pour la réhabilitation et la
réaffectation du patrimoine bâtisse que
j'ai eu la naïveté de croire dans un
premier temps on obtient l'effet inverse
une commission d'enquête sénatoriale qui
vise à évaluer l'efficacité des
politiques de l'État en matière de
rénovation énergétique va démarrer ses
travaux j'ai la chance d'en faire partie
et je voudrais profiter de cette
opportunité pour identifier les leviers
d'action qui permettraient de
solutionner en urgence c'est impensé se
malentendu réglementaire avant qu'il ne
soit trop tard pour notre patrimoine
bâti celui qui humanise nos territoires
confèrent à notre pays l'identité qui
est la sienne celui qui permet de mettre
en oeuvre et de transmettre des
savoir-faire exceptionnels et qui
contribue à l'attractivité touristique
et dynamisme économique de nos régions
plusieurs levées d'action pourraient
être mobilisées pour éviter que les
travaux de rénovation ne se traduisent
par la perte de patrimoine et de
savoir-faire ainsi que par un gaspillage
d'argent public et nous voudrions
profiter de cette table ronde pour avoir
votre avis sur certains d'entre eux même
si vous l'avez déjà fait tout à l'heure
dans vos interventions alors faudrait-il
selon vous revoir les DPE pour les
adapter aux spécificités des différents
types de bâties sachant que des travaux
de modélisation du comportement
thermique du bâti ancien réalisé par le
crébal et CAE on l'a entendu tout à
l'heure permettrait déjà de le faire et
dans ce cas là se donner les moyens de
le faire le plus vite possible vu
l'urgence
sachant qu'une récente petite étude que
choisir à montrer que les diagnostics
énergétiques confiés à différents
diagnostiqueurs sur un même bâtiment
donne des résultats très différents que
pensez-vous des conditions dans
lesquelles sont réalisés ces DPE
pensez-vous que les diagnostiquers sont
suffisamment formés
et enfin on sait que la question de
l'inventaire et de la protection du bâti
sont des sujets sensibles pour les élus
qu'il a considèrent souvent avec
réticence pensez-vous que
l'identification du petit patrimoine non
protégé par d'autres dispositifs et son
inscription dans les documents
d'urbanisme avec des préconisations
adaptées comme cela se fait déjà dans
les PLU qui ont intégré ce type de
problématique devrait être rendu
obligatoire et bénéficier à ce titre de
moyen humain et financiers mis à
disposition par l'État pour aider les
collectivités à la mettre en œuvre je
vous remercie
première série de questions à la fois
sur les DPE et puis aussi sur le petit
patrimoine non protégé avec en fait la
question qu'est-ce qu'on fait maintenant
on a bien compris que vous vous
travaillez sur des solutions que les
moyens étaient mis en oeuvre pour
approfondir la connaissance mais
néanmoins il y a une loi qui s'applique
avec des pressions qui se font dès
aujourd'hui sur les propriétaires
qu'est-ce qu'on fait dans les jours et
les semaines qui viennent je ne sais pas
qui veut commencer à répondre
ah pardon madame du Tertre
quand une commune engage un PLU ou un
plui elle peut faire appel à une aide
financière qui est en général défini et
versé par les DDT on pourrait imaginer
il faut savoir que cette haine n'est pas
toujours demandé par les communes on
critique le montant de l'élaboration
d'un PLU ou d'un PLU mais on ne fait pas
forcément appel à l'aide on pourrait
conditionner cette aide à la réalisation
de l'identification vous avez raison de
mots inventaire fait peur mais
l'identification du bâti qui échappe aux
enjeux de protection qui sont déjà en
place c'est pas difficile de cerner où
sont les périmètres des abords et de
regarder le tissu urbain ancien les
conditionner l'Aide publique au plui sur
cette identification sa prise en compte
et les préconisations qui pourront être
peut-être ça je ne sais pas fait à
l'échelle département fondamentale aux
régionales c'est ça c'est un des sujets
à réfléchir avec vous monsieur Hébert
monsieur Avignon la pertinence de
l'échelle de ces préconisations c'est
difficile à cerner
deux questions vous avez posées revoir
les DPE ça me paraît absolument
indispensable je crois qu'on est à peu
près tous d'accord ici dans nos
interventions
et directeur des patrouilles la
souligner dans le ministère
effectivement au travail sur tous ces
sujets il y a des propositions
intéressantes qui sont faites mais il
faut commencer par ça et il faut
certainement avoir des diagnostiqueurs
spécialisés sur le patrimoine on ne peut
pas traiter la même façon d'abord parce
que il faut partir du fait que on l'a
plusieurs d'entre nous ont souligner
mais un patrimoine étant soit quelque
chose vertueux par rapport au fait que
on évite de construire quelque chose et
même les architectes aujourd'hui le
disent c'est c'est ce que je rappelais
c'est ce que défend la présidence dans
un architecte et d'ailleurs dans
l'évolution des formations et c'est très
intéressant ce que Jean-François aime
bien souligné parce que c'est une
position très rapide mais au fond les
professeurs encore c'est pas intégré
dans le cycle c'est en train de le faire
mais dans le signe de formation c'est ça
que je voulais préciser tout à l'heure
sur la question du PLU alors la
transformation de pluie on est plusieurs
à avoir des expériences de mer ici
d'abord il faut bien différencier le PLU
lorsqu'il est devenu intercommunal ou
lorsqu'il est communal moi
personnellement j'ai toujours plaidé
plutôt sur le PLU communal parce que
quand on est sur l'intercommunalité le
souci que l'on a sur la question du
préservation du patrimoine peut-être
moins fort tout simplement parce que le
même même s'il est pas sensible à ça sa
population est censive à ça et quand
vous traitez au niveau d'une
intercommunalité je préside une
intercommunité il y a 18 communes
la question est beaucoup plus délicate
et on est beaucoup plus indépendant par
rapport à la pression que font les
associations donc déjà c'est extrêmement
différent lorsqu'on se met en plu
communal ou intercommunale je crois
qu'en tout cas est la proposition qui a
été faite à l'instant par
âme sénatrice je la trouve très
intéressante oui c'est vrai qu'il
faudrait que on est la possibilité d'en
documents d'urbanisme notamment avec le
soutien toutes les associations parce
qu'elles connaissent bien le patrimoine
d'avoir des protections qui permettent
d'éviter les destructions trop rapides
parce que tous les maires ne sont pas
sensibles à cette question et je citer
le cas tout à l'heure des collègues
extrêmement bien par ailleurs mais
soumis à une pression de construire très
forte parce que une urgence là ça peut
être le cas de répondre par exemple à un
déficit en logement social et bien ils
vont être amenés à détruire un bâtiment
parce que il construis aussi un immeuble
alors que ce bâtiment est une identité
forte de leur ville au village donc oui
je pense que c'est intéressant de faire
cette évolution à nos associations
étroites il a aussi je crois que le rôle
et les CAE moi je regarde beaucoup des
sérieuses sont conceptuellement un outil
formidable mais dans la pratique il y a
de telle différence
c'est ça le problème donc sauf si on
arrivait à des saluts qui sont tous
performants dotés de personnes je pense
qu'il faut donc arriver peut-être à un
mix est-ce que le ministère peut avoir
cette souplesse avec de temps en temps
il y a des fondations de la Fondation
patrimoine est très très présente dans
certains départements c'est inégal
départemental mais ils ont fait un gros
train trouver le bon référent le bon
référent qui va aider le maire à
construire et les associations on appuie
pour avoir des protections intelligentes
je me suis Avignon
oui sur le sur les propositions de me le
rapporteur je fais qui ment sur le DPH
je crois qu'on a et vous le rappeliez le
fait que certains diagnostics réalisés
sur le même bien puis ça boutire à
vraiment une très grande variabilité des
résultats et les indices à la fois à mon
sens que
des éléments de dispositif du DPE of
pouvoir être perfectionné mais aussi et
surtout qu'on doit travailler sur la
qualité de son application de sa mise en
œuvre avoir davantage de contrôle
effectivement pour vérifier la qualité
de de la mise en oeuvre de ces mêmes
normes puisque là en l'occurrence les
mêmes normes appliquées par des
diagnostiqueurs différents aboutissent à
des résultats parfois très très
différents et un peu choquant donc on a
on a en conscience effectivement de de
ce sujet je crois effectivement que
qu'un exercice et un travail
interministériel nécessaire sur sur
cette question et qu'il a qu'il y a
aujourd'hui une prise de conscience que
on ne va pas parce que le DPE est à
juste titre et vu comme a été vu comme
un véritable progrès
nombreux pour l'appréhension de la
performance et le l'affichage de de
résultat qui parfois engage ensuite très
lourdement financièrement les personnes
qui se qui acquièrent les biens qui vont
y avoir et faire des travaux donc le le
on a parfois eu le sentiment que revenir
sur le DPE elle est portée atteinte à
son principe et à sa diffusion et à sa
généralisation je crois que c'est pas
c'est pas le cas bon on pense
aujourd'hui qu'effectivement on doit
pouvoir avoir des adaptations et alors
je ne sais pas ensuite s'il faut qu'il y
ait une catégorie de diagnostiqueur
spécifique au patrimoine mais il faut
assurément qu'il y ait une méthodologie
spécifique elle ou à ce patrimoine
ancien se bâtit ancien qui se nourrira
justement
des éléments de constat de recherche
avec tous ceux qui se connaissent
justement de la diversité de ces là
encore ça ne va pas être la même chose à
la limite d'établir un DPE dans des
bâtiments de ta ville François et ceux
de Charleville-Mézières ou construction
on vient piquant davantage la brique ou
encore dans d'autres d'autres régions de
France sur le second point là je suis
hors de des compétences du président de
l'ADEME mais probablement puis-je comme
maire de Charleville-Mézières avoir un
avis sur le sur la question et je crois
qu'effectivement étendre les périmètres
de protection de manière adaptée et
certainement une bonne réponse aussi à
ce la problématique que vous exprimez
parce que
lorsque dans l'exemple que tu donnais
tout à l'heure François la destruction
d'un bâtiment c'est parce qu'il n'était
certainement pas protégé on était sur du
bâtiment du bâti ancien non protégé on a
pu procéder de cette manière donc
effectivement étendre de manière adaptée
la protection
on a eu la chance et c'est natrice elle
se Joseph à qui posait ce qui suivait ce
dossier personnellement pendant de
nombreuses années on a eu la chance
d'avoir à Charleville-Mézières un site
patrimonial remarquable un PSMV qui
couvre à peu près à mon avis comme ça à
vue de nez au moins 80 à 90 % du bâti
ancien de la ville donc effectivement
dans ce périmètre là aujourd'hui toutes
ces questions de rénovation elles sont
vus avec avec la BF et je crois de
manière
pertinente par rapport à l'objectif de
protection ça n'est effectivement pas le
cas partout et et bon la lourdeur de la
démarche malgré tout peut
pourrait en dissuader certains il nous a
fallu nous 20 ans pour pour arriver à le
l'obtenir ce PSMV ce site patrimonial
remarquable mais mais peut-être qu'il y
a-t-il moyen de trouver une protection
intermédiaire adaptée qui permettrait
effectivement de mieux concilier les
objectifs de préservation du patrimoine
et
et d'adaptation et d'entrée de ce bâti
dans une aire où on doit effectivement
consommer moins d'énergie au mètre carré
à peu près partout sans quoi ce sont nos
concitoyens qui supporteront un prix
excessif
merci je vais prendre toutes les
questions en vous demandant chers
collègues d'être
synthétique dans vos formulations et je
vais commencer par sonner de la pauvreté
merci monsieur le Président merci
beaucoup de vos interventions
respectives sur un sujet qui voulait
bien compris lors des discussions
budgétaires nous a beaucoup occupé
puisque c'est le sujet en ce moment qui
concerne le patrimoine parce que s'il y
a une urgence énergétique et
environnementale il y a une urgence pour
le patrimoine parce que
le DPE est sorti les tous s'appliquent
il y a des deadlines le calendrier T3 et
du coup il y a urgence à produire à
contreproduire quelque chose donc certes
moi j'entends bien que le ministère
travaille depuis longtemps sur ces
sujets là en revanche justement parce
qu'il y a probablement un travail depuis
longtemps partout dans les territoires y
compris dans les Dracs sur ces questions
parce que dans les draps on sait bien
que que toutes les les personnes en
charge du patrimoine sont en capacité de
faire des propositions sur les
caractéristiques patrimoniales précises
des territoires sur lesquels ils
exercent leur métier
il me semble qu'on devrait pouvoir
arriver à quelque chose qui ferait
évoluer le DPE si ce n'est rapidement en
tout cas production de fiches pratiques
assez rapidement d'autant plus qu'il y a
pas mal de SPR et que les SPR ça dose
sur des caractéristiques du bâti très
différents d'une commune à l'autre et
que donc CCAS sont de formidables outils
pour faire évoluer très rapidement pour
peu qu'on en fasse la synthèse
évidemment au plan national les critères
du DPE est proposé des fiches de
formation aux professionnels qui
interviennent notamment les
diagnostiqueurs
mon deuxième donc voilà en fait il est
temps qu'on ait un calendrier pour ce
sujet
le deuxième mois deuxième intervention
concerne les questions financières et
fiscales puisqu'on sait bien que c'est
un peu le nerf de la guerre dans dans
cette affaire outre les considérations
écologiques et environnementales on a
besoin aussi
d'un financement spécifique et
[Musique]
soit grande petite ou moyenne de France
on puisse là où c'est utile l'utiliser
ce qui donnerait une aide financière
substantielle en tout cas pour pouvoir
mettre à niveau de façon massive parce
que la question c'est la question de la
massification pour être efficace et en
l'état que les choses on ne l'est pas en
ce qui concerne la massification il y a
une question particulière qui est celui
du patrimoine de la reconstruction
chaque bâtiment n'étant pas forcément
patrimonial en lui-même mais c'est
l'ensemble urbain qu'il est et donc là
on est encore dans un autre sujet avec
des copropriétés de voilà au moins une
centaine de copropriétaires de la
plupart des cas dans les grandes villes
et puis des copropriétés qui n'existent
pas ou qui sont pas structurés dans les
plus petites villes et donc on a un vrai
sujet parce que pour le coup on sait que
ce patrimoine là c'était remis à niveau
ça ferait en matière de bilan carbone
une économie extrêmement substantielle
au niveau au niveau national donc est-ce
qu'il est prévu un travail spécifique
sur ce patrimoine qui est donc
du béton et pour lequel on n'a pas
forcément
la possibilité en tout cas si on veut
pas défigurer la ville de mettre du
bardage extérieur enfin de l'isolation
par l'extérieur mais c'est bien par
l'intérieur quelque chose doivent se
jouer enfin moi ma dernière intervention
porte sur le crébat qui est cette
fameuse institution un peu formelle
informelle qui a été qui est une
émanation du cerema mais dans quel
travail un certain nombre
d'interlocuteurs associatifs
et autres concernés par le
patrimoine
à ma connaissance mais peut-être que ça
évolué il y a plus de
d'agents en charge du crébat 3 il
semblerait trois équivalents temps plein
est-ce qu'il est prévu que cette fameuse
structure qui a déjà produit beaucoup
travaillé beaucoup et qui serait même
quasiment capacité de produire les
fiches de maintenant est-ce qu'il
pourrait faire évoluer le DPE est-ce
qu'il est prévu que cette structure
devient une structure très officielle
très structurée et un peu plus outils
puisqu'elle est en capacité parce
qu'elle représente quasiment la
terminale ministériel de produire les
outils dont nous avons besoin sur le
terrain je vous remercie
Sylvie Robert
merci merci monsieur le Président et
merci beaucoup pour vos pour vos
interventions je commencerai par dire
que c'est un sujet mais Jean-François
Hébert l'a dit très politique au sens
des politiques publiques et il est
complexe parce que à la fois d'abord
c'est une urgence que cette transition
écologique mais il est complexe parce
que c'est la conciliation des contraires
et on voit bien dans vos interventions
que
vraiment la et c'est aussi notre notre
réflexion permanente ici c'est de
trouver le bon curseur pour justement
concilier les contraires en sachant
qu'il ne faudrait pas que c'est urgence
mais vous l'avez dit soit l'occasion de
céder à quelques facilités voire même de
remettre en question quelques principes
et je pense à la question des avis
conformes des ABS et on voit que à la
faveur d'un certain nombre de textes et
bien celui-ci est toujours très fragile
et donc je souhaitais je souhaitais le
dire tout comme d'ailleurs et je moi je
n'ai pas de Dieu dans mon département
mais je mesure vraiment l'importance des
CAE dans ce dans ce contexte très très
particulier parce que c'est vrai que
cette question arrive dans un contexte
très particulier et quand je disais tout
à l'heure très politique c'est que cette
question touche les modes d'habiter vous
l'avez dit mais touche aussi les
représentations
arrivent en pleine tension sur le
logement en Bretagne on est vraiment
confronté à cette question dans certains
territoires donc c'est un vrai sujet et
puis et percuté aussi par la question
énergétique et ce qui se passe à partir
d'aujourd'hui sur les factures
énergétiques d'un certain nombre de nos
de nos concitoyens ce sujet Sabine le
disait est percuté aussi en tout cas et
touché par des par des lois plusieurs
lois des crèches par revenir climat et
résilience et le zinne mais bon les EnR
il y a peu de temps on voit bien que en
tout cas ce contexte est aussi très
important et puis il touche à des
notions
qui sont assez intéressantes et là aussi
qui
questionne l'ADEME le céréma la NCT des
questions à la fois d'ingénierie et
d'expertise c'est pas la même chose et
je crois que là aussi il faut en tout
cas en avoir absolument le la lucidité
et je dirais que si il y a des pistes de
réflexion qui qui effectivement concerne
le niveau d'expertise à atteindre
concernant les caractéristiques du bâti
ancien c'est aussi l'adaptation des
solutions techniques et la remise en
question en tout cas le questionnement
sur les modes de calcul de la
performance énergétique mais vous l'avez
dit alors moi j'aurais deux questions
puisque les autres ont été posés
comment garantir un niveau de compétence
suffisant qui concerne concernant les
spécificités du bâti ancien bien sûr
chez les opérateurs chargés
d'accompagner les ménages vous l'avez
dit Madame c'est un sujet alors quel
pour vous pour vous quelle serait les
solutions pour les accompagner dans la
réalisation de leur projet de rénovation
énergétique et deuxième question la
Commission européenne travaille
actuellement sur un projet de refonte de
sa directive sur la performance
énergétique des bâtiments qui pourraient
être finalisés au printemps prochain
donc très très prochainement et qui vise
l'instauration d'un référentiel commun
en matière de performance énergétique
minimale avez-vous de la visibilité sur
ces éléments qui seraient pris en compte
dans le cadre et de l'impact de la
refonte de cette directive je vous
remercie beaucoup
merci Thomas dessus
merci monsieur le Président moi je vais
avoir une seule question qui a assez
simple on a parlé de travail
interministériel l'indique Christophe
Béchu a indiqué qu'il fallait plutôt se
projeter la France dans un scénario à
plus 4 degrés de réchauffement d'ici
2100 alors que actuellement on était
plutôt sur des projections optimistes à
plus 2 degrés plus 4 degrés ça veut dire
un certain nombre d'impact sur nos
matériaux sur nos sols et sur notre bâti
la France actuelle ressemble à la France
actuelle parce qu'elle s'est construite
siècle apprécié dans un climat qui n'a
pas beaucoup varié et si elle ressemble
à ce qu'elle est pas à une ville du sud
de l'Espagne ou du nord de l'Afrique
c'est aussi parce que on a adapté notre
bâti à un climat tempéré voilà
et aujourd'hui on voit que ça va
s'accélérer ça va s'accélérer très très
fort très très vite donc j'ai entendu
qu'il y avait une feuille de route qui
était en construction au ministère de la
Culture j'ai entendu parler de travail
interministériel donc est-ce que cette
feuille de route travaille sur des
scénarios différents en fonction du
climat et l'impact que ça aura sur notre
bâti ancien sur notre patrimoine je
pense j'ai entendu ou c'était un peu
sous-entendu que parfois en présentait
la rénovation comme une menace sur notre
bâti ancien je pense qu'un une France a
plus 4 degrés et bien plus dangereuse
pour notre bâti ancien nos paysages et
la France qu'on connaît merci
merci monsieur le Président merci pour
la qualité de vos interventions moi
j'aimerais revenir un tout petit peu
parce que c'est dans la théorité sur le
projet de loi relatif à l'accélération
de la production puisque le texte a été
voté hier par par l'Assemblée nationale
et vous savez que l'Assemblée nationale
a introduit une modification
substantielle de l'article
l32 pardon-2 du code du code du
patrimoine je vous rappelle cet article
il donne à l'ABF le soin de s'assurer du
respect de l'intérêt public attaché au
patrimoine et l'assemblée à ajouter une
petite phrase que je vous lis il tient
compte des objectifs nationaux de
développement de l'exploitation des
énergies renouvelables ce qui est ce qui
est ce qui pose un problème d'abord
de droit parce qu'on touche à
l'indépendance des législations et on
subordonne la législation patrimoine
patrimoniale à celle de l'énergie ce qui
est un précédent fâcheux et par ailleurs
pratiquement je ne vois pas comment
l'ABF et vous nous direz comment vous
allez faire
concrètement dans un tarte dans un
département va pouvoir instruire en
rendant compatible son analyse
architecturale et une déclinaison
gouvernementale dans le dans le
département des objectifs climatiques
nationaux il faudra que vous nous disiez
comment comment vous allez comment vous
allez faire je trouve qu'il y a là une
modification d'émission des des ABS qui
est très préjudiciable parce que ça
brouille encore leur leur
pouvoir d'instruction par ailleurs ce
que je regrette vraiment dans ce texte
c'est que n'est vu le patrimoine que
sous l'angle de la production d'énergie
et pas sous l'angle de la consommation
d'énergie or l'ABF parce qu'il a à cœur
de maintenir un bâti ancien il a aussi
un rôle très fort dans la préservation
de la consommation
d'abord parce qu'on l'a dit ici c'est
plus intéressant de rénover que de
détruire plus de reconstruire et que
très souvent vous l'avez dit le bâti
ancien il a des capacités de résilience
à des modifications du climat qui sont
exceptionnelles la maison familiale que
j'occupe sur le plateau de mille vache
elle est munie d'une d'une climatisation
corréienne qui est extrêmement efficace
les murs font un mètre donc même quand
il fait 42 heures à l'intérieur vous
êtes bien fait 22 voilà c'était pour
répondre à mon collègue sur la capacité
justement du bâti à pouvoir résister à
ce genre de choses moi je pense au
contraire ce qui serait intéressant
c'est de donner plus de latitude et de
et de et de moyens aux ABS pour contrer
pour contrôler les permis de démolir et
je pense que ça serait intéressant que
l'État montre l'exemple je prends juste
un exemple qui concerne le département
des Hauts-de-Seine à Malakoff il y a un
bâtiment qui est un inter architectural
qui a été occupé avant par l'INSEE ça se
trouve porte de vent vous le voyez en
prenant le périphérique c'est quasiment
le même que celui qui abrite la
Commission européenne à Bruxelles
l'état décidé de le raser pour le
reconstruire ce qui est une absurdité
sans nom ça aurait été beaucoup plus
intéressant de procéder à sa rénovation
mais pour le ministère de la Santé en
l'occurrence c'est beaucoup plus simple
de de pas s'embêter de raser la parcelle
et de reconstruire un bâtiment dans
l'intérêt architectural est quasiment
nulle enfin ça c'est mon point de vue
mon point de vue
d'esthète donc je crois que là
l'agence de transition écologique aurait
un rôle à jouer en interministériel pour
expliquer à certains ministériel
certains ministères que des pratiques
anciennes qui considèrent qu'il est
toujours plus le plus simple de détruire
et de reconstruire aujourd'hui ne sont
plus envisageables et qu'il faut d'abord
travailler avec les services du
ministère de la Culture à une rénovation
de de ces bâtiments enfin je voudrais
finir sur le CAE parce que ma collègue
Anne vantalon dans son excellent rapport
sur la préservation des monuments
religieux a montré que c'était sans
doute un des éléments fondamentaux parce
que ils assurent la proximité dans la
gestion de de tout ce bâti et j'aimerais
rappeler que les AE ont l'immense mérite
d'avoir une fiscalité propre puisqu'ils
sont financés en partie par une par la
part départementale de la taxe
d'aménagement donc les départements
pourraient s'emparer du CE pour en faire
en complément avec les services de la
DRAC des outils de proximité
service de la rénovation merci monsieur
le président
elle sait Joseph
merci monsieur le Président vous êtes
compliqué de d'être original dans les
questions je voudrais déjà remercier
tous les intervenants parce que beaucoup
de réponses ont été apportées beaucoup
de questions également de mes de mes
collègues nous partageons évidemment les
diagnostics et les inquiétudes sur le
DPE en particulier donc en secteur
sauvegardé en secteur où il y a du bâti
ancien parce que c'est vrai que les
matériaux les techniques ont évoqué ont
évolué et justement je vais rebondir sur
une question tout à l'heure par rapport
à ma ville d'origine sur les villes
notamment qui ont qui disposent de PSMV
ou de ou de SPR il y a une vraie crainte
aujourd'hui pour les pour les élus
locaux parce que on a de nombreuses
règles qui se surimposent et avec une
crainte pour que les bailleurs publics
et ou les bailleurs privés délaissent
davantage c'est centre-ville historiques
pour lesquelles en général on fait
beaucoup ça a été évoqué via différents
éléments pour redynamiser ces secteurs
la rénovation
des logements secteurs sauvegardés
concernent quand même 46% des communes
et donc c'est encore plus vrais
aujourd'hui avec cette obligation
d'engager des travaux de rénovation
énergétique pour pouvoir louer ses biens
voilà donc pas une question très
originale mais surtout des inquiétudes
notamment aujourd'hui pour aménager et
adapter ces secteurs notamment en termes
de bornes de recharge ou tout à l'heure
ça a été évoqué matière de panneaux
photovoltaïques et puis pour terminer je
partage évidemment les préconisations de
mes collègues sur le c.ae puisque je
fais je vais peut-être le bonheur ou la
malchance d'être un des 7 départements
il y a pas de CAE donc on y travaille
activement aujourd'hui pour que les
Ardennes se dotent de cet outil
important merci comment
j'en profite pour ça que je pose la
question
genre
merci monsieur le Président ça sera très
rapide ma question s'adresse à François
demazir dont je salue
la vision concrète de maire et c'est
largement appréciable mais c'est une
question comme nous sommes également
dans la commission sport
qui touche un petit peu à la transition
énergétique au sport comment va-t-il
sortir du sujet de l'éclairage du stade
montboron par rapport au club de
Versailles qui a quelques chances de
croisons les doigts de monter en Ligue 2
le stade montboron en faisant partie du
patrimoine sportif du 78 et en tant que
voisin légèrement intéressé comme vous
l'aurez compris
Annick billon
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
messieurs pour toutes vos interventions
et déjà les réponses que vous avez pu
apporter j'ai
identifié trois types de freins et
difficultés en réalité vers la
rénovation et la préservation du Pâtis
ancien à la fois vous l'avez dit les
normes la loi les documents d'urbanisme
le DPE donc on a au fur et à mesure des
années apporter un certain nombre de
contraintes or on le voit ces
contraintes n'ont pas été suffisantes
pour préserver le petit patrimoine donc
qu'est-ce que vous proposez est-ce qu'il
faut étendre les aidpp par exemple
est-ce qu'il faut les multiplier est-ce
qu'elles ont été efficaces c'est ma
première question sur le deuxième type
de frein c'était le déficit de formation
des architectes ça a été pointé au
départ il y a eu des réponses quid de la
formation des artisans quid de la
volonté véritablement de se former à des
nouveaux matériaux à des nouvelles
techniques et aussi finalement ça a pas
été des innovations parce que moi j'ai
dans mon territoire par exemple des
innovations en termes d'isolation et
notamment avec la ouate de cellulose et
on le voit la puissance des grosses
industries dans l'isolation empêche des
innovations performantes de ce
multiplier et de se développer sur le
territoire c'est le cas pour l'isolation
mais c'est le cas pour d'autres produits
innovants donc comment fait-on pour que
véritablement des nouveaux matériaux
puissent arriver sur le marché sans que
les normes ISO et certifications r2020
etc finalement ne les empêche d'arriver
sur ce marché c'est valable pour
l'habitation l'habitat mais c'est aussi
valable dans d'autres secteurs ensuite
le troisième Fring que j'ai pu
identifier dans vos interventions ce
sont évidemment les prix de la
rénovation et pour avoir un exemple dans
le département de la Vendée vous aviez
un centre historique extrêmement avec un
bâti ancien extrêmement riche
l'impossibilité pour les propriétaires
de finalement l'entretenir on est arrivé
avec finalement une situation
aujourd'hui ou ce sont des marchands de
sommeil le centre-ville le Centre Bourse
est totalement déserté et tous les
toutes les habitants en capacité de se
construire ou d'acheter des maisons avec
des normes et des inconforts spécifiques
et bien ce sont reportés sur l'extérieur
donc comment aujourd'hui avec quels
outils on va réussir à apporter cette
aide et donc quels outils fiscaux comme
l'a dit Sonia de la pauvreté tout à
l'heure quels outils qu'elles aident on
va on va pouvoir apporter pour que ses
propriétaires puissent
apporter des logements non plus
insalubres non plus des marchands de
sommeil mais des vrais logements avec
cette difficulté donc quels outils
ensuite moi j'avais une question ayant
été en charge de l'urbanisme et
d'aménagement du territoire sur la
commune des Sables-d'Olonne notamment
quid des changements de destination
est-ce que pour vous c'est un frein
parce que on a été souvent confronté
lorsqu'on est adjoint à l'urbanisme des
difficultés pour passer d'un d'une
utilisation d'un d'un local à finalement
un commerce qui n'a plus lieu d'être et
c'est une réalité à un logement hors
manque de logement cruellement donc
comment réussir à assouplir ses normes
pour que des changements de destination
puissent permettre à des commerces qui
n'ont plus lieu d'être là où ils étaient
100 places de parking de pouvoir se
transformer en logement et puis toutes
les questions de revitalisation
centre-ville s'entrebour vous l'avez dit
nous qui sommes élus des territoires
ruraux il y a une vraie un vrai
engagement du Sénat avec cette toutes
ces propositions qui avaient été faites
et moi vous entendre j'ai entendu toute
l'expertise que vous avez pu apporter au
cours de cette table ronde mais
mais aussi le sentiment que si on y
arrive pas à préserver notre patrimoine
c'est peut-être qu'on a beaucoup
d'expertises qui travaillent chacun dans
leur silo et il y a peut-être pas
suffisamment de table ronde au Sénat
pour vous rassembler tous ensemble
autour de la table merci à vous
et en fin d'année
merci monsieur le Président donc je
salue à mon tour chacun des intervenants
et les remercie également pour la
richesse de leurs interventions en tant
que sénatrice des Yvelines je
souhaiterais saluer plus
particulièrement françois de Mazières le
maire d'une des plus belles villes
patrimoniale qui se trouve être dans mon
département donc de nombreux sujets ont
été déjà évoqués par mes collègues et je
m'associe évidemment à leurs
interrogations le bâti ancien est
évidemment un patrimoine de proximité
qui constitue l'âme de nos
centres-villes et de nos centres bourg
évidemment la vie des ABS est
fondamentale il n'est pas question ici
de remettre en cause leur expertise mais
aujourd'hui on peut constater que la
relation entre les élus et les
architectes des bâtiments de France
avait parfois complexe du fait de l'été
rogénéité voir des contradictions dans
les recommandations et prescriptions
émises selon l'architecte qui traite les
dossiers alors à l'heure de la
transition écologique les élus craignent
que cette que cette la difficulté à
laquelle il se heurte est un impact
négatif sur la préservation de
l'identité de leur bâti et de leur
projet donc quelle solution peuvent être
proposées pour éviter qu'ils ne se
retrouve dans cette situation je vous
remercie toute dernière question de
Monique Marco oui je vous remercie et
j'espère qu'elle issue de cette ronde
nous aurons peut-être une feuille route
plus détaillée avec un calendrier précis
c'est un petit peu la demande que nous
avons tous ici je rappelle que vous avez
évoqué plusieurs pistes comment faire
évoluer les DPE les DPE mais quel avec
une méthodologie adaptée moi je voudrais
avoir des précisions ensuite en parlant
de formation il faut quand même
constater que
j'insiste là dessus ce qui les
informations en école d'architecture
c'est des étudiants qui poussent
actuellement à ce que l'on est forme
justement à ces nouvelles approches par
rapport au climat et je dois dire qu'on
a quand même un grand temps de retard
ici en France et souhaiterait quand même
que que vous en preniez conscience et
faire en sorte que ce soit on va dire
une obligation cette formation soit
diffusée dans les écoles d'architecture
et c'est pareil pour la formation
professionnelle sincèrement ce n'est pas
suffisant les professionnels n'ont pas
suffisamment de possibilités d'être
formé quoi qu'il en soit donc on
continue comme avant et moi j'estime
aujourd'hui qui a urgence et je
souhaiterais savoir quand est-ce que
vous allez pouvoir communiquer cette
feuille de route interministérielle quel
calendrier vous avez et pourquoi parce
que aujourd'hui et comme disait mon
collègue nous sommes quand même dans
différents scénarios il faudrait
peut-être aussi adapter en fonction de
ce qui nous attend concernant l'impact
du changement climatique voilà je vais
vous laisser répondre alors évidemment
pas chacun à toutes les questions mais
peut-être prenez celle qui vous concerne
le plus directement et je vais commencer
par Jean-François Hébert merci beaucoup
je vais pas répondre à tout évidemment
mais en plus il nous faudrait un
ministère du logement avec la table
ronde aussi pour répondre à beaucoup de
questions mais bon
en tout cas il y a un point commun
beaucoup de bonnes interventions c'est
l'urgence et on la partage évidemment
donc pour ce qui est du calendrier des
sujets que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
discussions interministériales c'est
dans l'année qu'il faut évidemment
déboucher on a été relativement vite
pour les panneaux photovoltaïques c'est
un sujet qu'on a traité en 22 23 la
feuille de route pour moi celle que j'ai
évoquée sur le plan interministériel
donc on est plusieurs donc à coordonnées
c'est le ministère de la Culture qui
fera des propositions et on les
soumettra à nos collègues du MTE c'est
dans donc dans l'année pour le DPE comme
je le disais tout à l'heure et puis pour
les menuiseries c'est déjà de sujets
importants c'est-à-dire on touche les
sujets importants de l'isolation en
thermique des des
bâtiments anciens je reviens pas sur la
formation des ensa moi je maintiens que
les étudiants aujourd'hui sont très très
engagés c'est vraiment une dominante
très forte de leur de leur scolarité
c'est dans les programmes des écoles
évidemment il y a un petit temps de
retard de la formation des enseignants
mais il rattrape le retard et j'ai bon
espoir que ça se fasse très vite parce
que un mouvement de fond extrêmement
puissant j'ai noté que beaucoup de
d'intervenants ont insisté sur l'utilité
je m'en réjouis des instruments de
protection du patrimoine les SPR ont été
beaucoup cités les PSMV etc tout ce qui
est en découle donc on voit bien que
c'est totalement structurant pour le
sujet qui nous occupe parce que si les
bâtiments sont protégés on peut faire
intervenir l'architecte des bâtiments de
France il peut faire évoluer les projets
et ça devrait être un grand argument que
le Sénat a utilisé en disant mais quand
on prend les sujets en amont qu'on a un
professionnel qui peut intervenir on
démine et il y a peut-être des
difficultés au début et puis on arrive à
un projet qui acceptable pour la
collectivité et c'est vraiment très
important sur la feuille de route du
ministère qui n'est pas exactement celle
que j'ai évoquée avec les deux sujets le
mystères c'est vraiment l'ensemble du
ministère qui est impliqué dans cette
feuille de route portée par la ministre
ça va concerner les musées les archives
le spectacle vivant les médias c'est une
ambition très forte qui veut inscrire
l'ensemble du ministère dans cette
démarche de transition écologique et là
c'est probablement au printemps ou avant
le printemps que la feuille de route
ministérielle se sera donné qui n'est
pas donc uniquement concentré sur le
patrimoine bâti évidemment un petit mot
de leur rue parce que ça a été évoqué
par l'une d'entre vous moi j'ai fait des
démarches auprès de notre collègue de
rue pour faire en sorte que et on voit
que là aussi les choses évoluent on
arrête de donner de l'argent uniquement
pour détruire mais qu'on donne aussi de
l'argent pour garder pour maintenir
voilà ça c'est quelque chose qui
commence à se faire et sur beaucoup de
projets on sent ce changement également
qui est à l'oeuvre sur la Commission
européenne qui a évoqué Sylvie Robert en
est impliqué dans les travaux je suis
pas en capacité de vous dire aujourd'hui
le détail des choses pourrait envoyer
une petite note à la commission si si
vous l'acceptez
je suis pas compétent pour le crébat je
sais pas qui qui
l'anime je sais juste qu'il a un rôle
extrêmement puissant de diffusion des
des normes il y a beaucoup de fiches
pratiques qui existent je le disais dans
mon intervention et le problème c'est la
diffusion de tout ça et c'est le gros
effort que nous devons faire aujourd'hui
pour que ces fiches arrivent au maître
d'ouvrage aux propriétaires et puis aux
professionnels évidemment il y a ce gros
sujet de la formation que vous avez
évoqué voilà je m'en tiendrai là pour ce
qui me concerne
le président donc effectivement
peut-être pour répondre aux aspects qui
me concerne davantage encore que sur le
DPE je vous exprimais ce qui je crois et
relève effectivement du bon sens il y a
un certain nombre de dysfonctionnements
qui sont qui sont constatés avec
d'applications divergente et donc on
partage cette idée qu'il aurait lieu d'y
revenir et puis surtout de travailler
ensuite à
une harmonisation et de la mise en
oeuvre et de ce diagnostic de
performance énergétique c'est un
exercice qui est dans l'exercice
réglementaire qui donc relève là pour le
coup de la DG AlN direction générale de
l'aménagement du logement et donc c'est
vraiment le ministère du logement qu'il
faudrait effectivement
interroger sur ce sujet pour connaître
les le calendrier en la matière et
et les conditions un peu globales de
mise en oeuvre on a nous à la dame eu
une expertise sur ce sujet qu'on
mobilisera naturellement
au soutien et à l'appui de cette
évolution de du DPE et surtout on
dispose aussi de moyens d'intervention
et de formation à destination d'un
certain nombre de filières
professionnels notamment des artisans du
bâtiment que nous mobiliserons le cas
échéant également
de la même manière
peut-être sur je suis pas le
porte-parole de Christophe Béchu
néanmoins j'étais lundi matin à la
conférence sur l'adaptation où il a
évoqué en réalité par pas le fait qu'on
allait changer de trajectoire
envisager une hausse plus 4 degrés mais
dans cet exercice de du programme
national d'adaptation au changement
climatique qu'il allait falloir avoir un
un
un itinéraire une transition une
trajectoire pardon qui soit plus
réaliste que celle des simplement des
plus de degrés et donc c'est dans ce
sens qu'il a indiqué qu'il y aurait dans
ce travail donc sur le programme
national d'adaptation changement
climatique 3 cette troisième que la
France doit concevoir cette année et
bien un une trajectoire à deux degrés
conforme à peu près à nos engagements
même si elle est déjà un peu supérieure
l'évolution mais c'est un et demi au
niveau national au niveau international
et donc ça peut signifier des hausses
plus importantes pour la France et donc
plus 4 degrés c'est sur l'adaptation et
l'adaptation ça n'est pas un sujet à
prendre de manière séparée mais c'est
vraiment un sujet à intégrer dans toutes
nos réflexions et assurément dans les
dans les travaux et la façon dont
conçoit les travaux donc
une cohérence à avoir avec les outils
qui existent ma prime rénov et d'autres
il faut il faut que les évolutions et
les investissements que qui vont être
soutenus qui sont encouragés aujourd'hui
quand ils sont encouragés sur des moyens
publics et bien finalement intègre cette
ce paramètre de l'adaptation qu'il va
nous falloir faire vivre effectivement
dans un contexte où on risque d'avoir
des notamment des sécheresses beaucoup
plus importantes des phénomènes
climatiques
un peu plus extrême que ceux sur
lesquels nous avions calés jusqu'à
présent nos anticipations donc dans le
dans l'ensemble des stratégies je crois
que ce sera le problème de la du PNA CC
national d'adaptation changement
climatique et bien il nous faudra au
prévoir et intégrer et notamment pour le
confort d'été ce sera extrêmement
important la façon qu'on va intégrer ça
dans la dans notre réglementation et les
dispositifs que nous soutiendrons en
termes de rénovation je
n'est pas observé pour répondre à ma
collègue de Charleville-Mézières que que
la création du PSMV du SPR est fait fuir
les investisseurs bien au contraire
plutôt le sentiment que ce type de
dispositif à un vrai attrait et
notamment le fait de pouvoir utiliser
les dispositif Malraux
a permis je crois le retour et donc
l'arrivée d'investisseurs qui qui
réalise des opérations de rénovation de
très belles qualités parce qu'on a là à
la fois des gens qui connaissent leur
métier qu'ils l'ont déjà fait dans
certains nombre de villes qui ont rénové
un centre de très beau centre ville
celui de 3 par exemple et qui maintenant
et bien viennent dans les villes qui
sont nouvellement labellisées sur
l'extension des des CAUE je ne peux que
souscrire moi ce projet ça me semble
effectivement extrêmement
utile d'autant que ce n'est pas toujours
le cas là cette fois-ci je reprends ma
casquette des Lucas c'est pas toujours
le cas c'est pas si fréquent que l'État
prévoit un financement préalable à une
mission donc là aujourd'hui il y a un
financement il existe et donc il serait
bien que la mission puisse dans les 7
départements je crois qui sont qui n'ont
pas encore ce dispositif sans dotés
surément ça c'est un progrès pour la
qualité de les constructions à tout ce
qui n'est pas relève pas de de la
protection la plus importante confiée
aux ABS sur le sur le comment on va on
va faire pour pour aider et soutenir les
rénovations et bien je crois que il y a
quand même aujourd'hui un certain nombre
de dispositifs d'outils qui qui sont en
place qui connaissent effectivement un
succès et relativement important ma
prime Réno son félicité fonctionne bien
c'est ce sur quoi nous travaillons de
depuis ce matin c'est les normes à
appliquer ou finalement les pratiques à
appliquer les pratiques à mettre en
oeuvre dans le cadre de ces dispositifs
je pense que les dispositif en eux-mêmes
ils sont plutôt plutôt bons vertueux
bien que la collectivité effectivement
soutienne cet effort de rénovation
juste pour redire tout à l'heure
l'effort c'est de passer de 41 000 rêvés
de l'innovation BBC par an à 700 000
donc
il marche ou plus exactement à une
succession de marche extrêmement
importante à franchir à faire et donc ce
dont on parle ici c'est effectivement je
crois d'avoir des pratiques surtout
s'agissant du bâti ancien qui soit
vraiment adapté à sa spécificité et
c'est ce à quoi nous ayons avec le
crébat notamment et bien de contribuer
mais je n'ai pas non plus de réponse sur
sur les moyens dont on dispose de Crévin
surtout si dans quelles conditions il
pourrait être augmenté
voilà moi ce que je pouvais vous
apporter comme élément de réponse
françois de Mazières
oui beaucoup de questions passionnantes
ont été posées
la question du DPE revient
systématiquement moi personnellement au
vu de tout ce qu'on a entendu ce matin
je pense qu'effectivement il est
important que vous ayez dans les
diagnostics des gens qui ont une
formation particulière pour le
patrimoine on ne peut pas traiter la
question patrimoine façon exactement
similaire à celle d'un bâtiment de
conception plus récente sur la question
aussi des ABS c'est vrai que dans les
villes qui ont qui sont l'objet de
protection particulière
Elisabeth sont un rôle de garant joue en
route de garant très important mais
aujourd'hui se pose la question leur nom
je le citais tout à l'heure quand vous
rendrez 4000 avis il est difficile pour
eux de prendre le temps nécessaire pour
réfléchir juste moi une adaptation des
dispositifs et notamment d'être plus
intelligent par la porte question la
conciliation de la priorité qui existe
réellement pour améliorer la transition
énergétique et en même temps de
préserver ce patrimoine or ça demande du
temps ça demande de l'adaptation donc il
y a une vraiment une question et quand
vous voyez qu'aujourd'hui il y a eu
enfin cette année je croyais trois
postes d'abf qui par des uniquement une
question d'ouverture de poste c'est
aussi question je crois de candidat il y
a une vraie inquiétude à avoir
et il faut il faut et le ministère bien
sûr s'y attelle mais il faut le
souligner
la question de la formation qu'on a
évoqué à plusieurs reprises c'est vrai
que le mystère actuellement fait des
efforts qui nous ont été rappelés
s'intéressant je voyais l'annonce du
projet résidant le premier palmarès
développement durable dans les écoles
d'archives c'est une initiative
intéressante
il n'empêche que il y a en effet de
rattrapage à faire au niveau des
formateurs et la question de l'artisanat
est extrêmement importante parce que
l'on voit dans des villes qui ont donc
un patrimoine important on voit qu'on a
un problème pour trouver les artisans
donc il faut aussi se pencher sur cette
question de artisans spécialisés dans ce
type de technique ça coûte plus cher
troisième point que je voudrais aborder
parce qu'il a été abordé par beaucoup
ici de parlementaires
comment faire pour améliorer le
financement alors je pense que la
question du label la Fondation
patrimoine est vraiment intéressante ça
a été un exemple ça a été un levier
efficace pourquoi pas l'ouvrir sur cette
question de l'amélioration de ce petit
prince patrimoine qui est notre
principal soucis j'ai bien entendu tout
ce qui a été dit par et c'est un triste
sénateurs c'est vrai que ces petits
patrimoine nous inquiète
particulièrement parce que lui fait
l'objet de très peu de protection et là
la Fondation du Patrimoine montré depuis
quelques années avec son système de
label qu'elle a un levier intéressant
car tout se ramène souvent une question
de financement dans la question du
financement il y a eu des propositions
qui ont été faites pour une fiscalité
particulière pour les matériaux
biosourcés l'usage je trouve que c'est
une idée aussi qui vous regardez plus
près certes ça a un coût mais si on veut
développer l'usage chanvre comme isolant
qui était finalement on le sait une
technique ancienne si l'on veut utiliser
le retour à la terre il y a des
expériences qui sont menées je pensais
exponenti Clotaire actuellement en
région Île-de-France il faut aussi qu'il
y a une incitation et l'incitation
fiscale sur les matériaux sera assez
déterminante car quand vous avez en face
des promoteurs c'est tout même l'aspect
sono et trébuchant qui a un moment est
déterminant
les certificats d'énergie on en a pas
parlé une certificat d'énergie sont des
outils très performants aujourd'hui je
me posais la question si on pouvait
imaginer que l'on ouvre la possibilité
de certificat d'énergie ciblée sur des
opérations de rénovation ce qui
permettrait notamment si vous voulez une
approche plus localisée c'est-à-dire
qu'on peut mobiliser des entreprises sur
rénover un patrimoine de proximité
bien sûr en coopération avec les élus il
y a quelque chose à travailler parce que
au fond quand on s'interroge sur le
financement il faut voir ce qui marche
quelles sont les outils efficaces
celui-ci est un outil efficace le
Malraux est un outil efficace
certains le critiquent mais c'est vrai
que nous qui avons pu le voir dans des
des
villes où qui font l'objet d'un plan de
sauvegarde c'est un outil c'est un
levier
parlementaire là l'a évoqué pourquoi pas
travailler dans cet esprit là regardez
quel est le coût budgétaire et quelle
est l'impact qui pourrait avoir voilà
enfin je voudrais souligner une chose
c'est la question des priorités moi dans
ma ville je suis très concerné par ces
questions personnellement très
impliquées sur la notion de ville verte
c'est mon combat depuis 15 ans
nous avons commencé à rénover nos grands
quartiers sociaux et là c'est vrai que
l'isolation elle est facile elle est
efficace et je souligne qu'il existe
énormément de soutien financier de la
part de l'État et qu'on arrive à faire
des rénovations qui permettent même de
transformer positivement des quartiers
mon plus grand quartier social on a fait
plus de 1300 rénovations d'appartements
et on en a profité pour transformer ce
quartier c'est à dire qu'on a fini
d'isolation par extérieur et on en
doublant de briquettes élégantes qui a
totalement changé par rapport à la
vision des barres blan qu'on avait avant
je pense que donc dans ces cas-là les
priorités ont fait des économies
d'énergie essentielles et pour les
personnes qui vivent ça a été formidable
qu'on les faits juste avant la crise de
l'énergie
et donc dans l'ordre des priorités il
faut aussi penser faisons des choses
efficaces on se pose pas des problèmes
par rapport à la préservation d'un
bâtiment historique où on sait que là on
est plus précieux de ce que l'on fait et
comme vous le rappeliez très bien quand
on vit dans un immeuble du XIXe qui a
des murs très épais je suis désolé en
été c'est la meilleure des
climatisations et c'est beaucoup mieux
que d'autres formes de climatisation et
ça il faut tout même le rappeler donc
réfléchissons dans nos priorités
aujourd'hui faisons des gros efforts et
avec l'aide de tous les
soutien financier qui existe mis en
place par les gouvernements successifs
et qui sont renforce aujourd'hui mais
peut-être soyons prudents pour ne pas
détruire ce qui fait la beauté de notre
patrimoine et donc la beauté nos coeurs
de ville ça me paraît absolument
essentiel
madame buttertre
votre pardon pour répondre à certaines
de vos questions il me semble d'une part
qu'il faut vraiment se pencher sur la
question des architectes exerçant
aujourd'hui parce qu'on a parlé
d'urgence et donc il faut s'appuyer sur
eux et les aider il y a plein de bons
volontaires faut pas exagérer donc il y
a la question de leur formation continue
et il y a la question de la non
rentabilité de ses missions c'est à dire
que quand on intervient sur un petit
bâtiment de trois logements dans un
centre bourg on a déjà du mal à trouver
les financements pour les travaux donc
quand on dit un pétitionnaire mon petit
gars pour avoir un bon projet faut que
tu rajoutes 10% de maîtrise d'oeuvre il
rigole et il met du polystyrène sauf si
un ABS qui lui dit non donc il y a
vraiment une question architecte il faut
qu'on le regarde ensuite pour mettre en
cohérence l'attente vis-à-vis du secteur
des protégés par nos protections
patrimoniales faut encore qui est des
professionnels aux usuades donc ça on se
renvoie tous on est conscient c'est pas
possible de bosser comme boss les UDA
pour aujourd'hui point faut être
réaliste on a parlé 200 fois de
cohérence là vous devez l'être en dehors
des secteurs urbains protégés il faut
rendre obligatoire une validation du
programme de travaux par un architecte
quel qu'il soit doux qu'ils viennent il
faut arriver à valider des programmes de
travaux avant d'obtenir des subventions
donc tout le bâti avant 48 il faut y
arriver que ce soit public ou privé
c'est colossal
mais on gagne de la pertinence dans
cette manière là
pour répondre à une question sur
l'accompagnement des des particuliers
aujourd'hui il a été mis en place des
Sardes des services d'accompagnement à
la rénovation énergétique il faut
arriver à marier un conseil d'architecte
quand on est sur un bâtiment avant 48 de
n'importe quel architecte c'est ça qu'il
faut qu'on arrive à mailler dans le
territoire il y a des conventions dans
certains savent donc si je dis pas de
bêtises les sards c'est toujours à
l'échelle départementale monsieur
Avignon si je dis pas de bêtises donc
dans certains ça il y a des conventions
avec des CAE avec des assosses du
patrimoine avec peut-être des services
patrimoine de départements il y a
beaucoup de départements qui en ont avec
des architectes du patrimoine en intègre
donc en interne donc on peut trouver ces
liens enfin pour soutenir le
développement des techniques liées au
biosourcés il faut que les marchés
publics de rénovation
d'exemple en Seine-et-Marne le marché du
chanvre il a été innové par des
agriculteurs c'est pas les gens du
bâtiment qui ont eu l'idée du chanvre ce
sont des agriculteurs qui en ont repéré
tout de suite en amont la capacité
d'abord à mieux gérer leur terre alors
je suis pas agricultrice mais j'ai
compris que ça restructure les sols
c'est le mot qu'on qui est employé
ensuite quand au sème du chanvre on
arrose pas on s'aime en avril on récolte
en octobre et on fait rien c'est pas une
blague quoi donc sur le plan
environnemental c'est génial ils ont mis
en place une industrie de transformation
eux-mêmes les agriculteurs ils sont
devenus des industriels et pendant 10
ans ils ont vendu leur chaîne vote la
petite fibre pour en faire du paillage
pour les chevaux c'est un peu à pleurer
et depuis quelques années à force de
militer à force d'être avec construire
en chambre à l'échelle nationale il y a
des chantiers publics des chantiers
privés qui montrent le rôle et nous le
bâtir ancien mais il faut qu'on se
servent du champ il y a pas que le champ
via la paille il y a tout ce qu'on veut
mais il faut y arriver et ça les acteurs
publics sont
obligatoires manquants des exemples
voilà mes petites contributions
le président merci mesdames et messieurs
sénateurs merci effectivement oui pardon
voilà voilà beaucoup de beaucoup de
questions donc comme voilà je ne pourrai
pas répondre à tout mais je vais je vais
rebondir sur un certain nombre de points
qu'on qui viennent d'être évoqués
d'abord pour reparler de la chaîne de la
chaîne de de construction du projet de
rénovation de l'habitat on a parlé des
architectes je pense que effectivement
je il est évident que la place de
l'architecte doit être développée doit
être mais aujourd'hui concrètement que
se passe-t-il sur le territoire
aucun architecte n'intervient sur un
projet de rénovation énergétique d'une
maison je parle d'une maison je parle
pas de bâtiments publics je parle d'une
maison aucun architecte d'une part parce
que ça a été dit le le
ce sont des missions qui rapportent pas
assez voilà voilà et d'autre part parce
que parce que les architectes sont pas
assez nombreux en France voilà et dans
certains départements j'ai des conf qui
me disent que
ils sont absolument ravis quand ils
voient un architecte arriver dans leur
bureau parce que parce que parce qu'ils
sont pas là ils sont peu disponibles et
puis et puis et puis d'autre part parce
que on a une chaîne de production qui
fait que comme architecte n'est pas
obligatoire mais la plupart du temps ça
va ben voilà ça va être c'est plutôt
l'artisan qui va être finalement la
première porte d'entrée voilà alors ça
ça doit nous questionner et ça doit
d'autant plus qu'une questionner parce
que comme je disais tout à l'heure nous
ce qu'on constate je le rappelle c'est
en gros 80% du budget mis sur 20% pour
obtenir 20% du résultat
donc ça ça pose la question du projet
global or le projet global il est
déterminant quand on fait un projet de
rénovation du bâti une rénovation
énergétique à la fois parce que ça
permet de traiter la qualité du bâti et
la rénovation énergétique ce projet
global il demande d'avoir une vision
globale du sujet et ça il faut qu'il y
ait des spécialistes des professionnels
spécialistes qui soient en situation de
le faire parce que ça permet
d'identifier les bons postes de donner
les bons conseils d'économiser de
l'argent alors nous c'est un boulot
qu'on fait régulièrement comme le haut
collègue du cue parce que quand on voit
les gens arriver en amont avec une
isolation par l'extérieur on va les
aider on va rentrer un peu dans leur on
prend du temps effectivement pareil un
4000 avis
par ce qu'on a 12000 avis en Finistère
donc voilà on est trois 4000 avis par
ABS bon mais on prend le temps quand
même on déconstruit on refait on reprend
et on finit par expliquer aux gens que
en faisant autrement finalement ils
mettront voilà mais c'est c'est rien du
tout c'est un c'est voilà donc cette
question du le projet global et qui fait
enfin voilà qui alimente ce projet
global qui est formé pour contribuer à
ce projet global avec évidemment
l'architecte mais aussi j'en parlais
tout à l'heure ça n'a pas été repris et
je pense que c'est fondamental la place
des ingénieurs thermiciens parce que
dans un projet aujourd'hui l'ingénieur
thermicien il est là et en fait il est
nulle part et on a les mêmes problèmes
avec les ingénieurs thermiciens qu'avec
les gens qui s'occupent des DPE voilà
veut dire que ils sont pas forcément
formés ils ont pas forcément le temps ni
l'énergie ni l'envie de
bousculer un petit peu les schémas
habituels et traditionnels voilà donc je
pense que ça ce sont des choses qui sont
qui sont importantes donc formation de
toute la filière effectivement parce que
comme je le disais comme ça a été redit
je pense que les artisans nous nos
artisans ont perdu la compétence c'est
pas qu'ils veulent pas le faire c'est
que ils ont perdu la compétence ils ont
perdu l'habitude et on voit bien que un
artisan un plaquiste ou un quelqu'un qui
fait de l'isolation quand il arrive dans
du bâti ancien bah il a pu les réflexes
il sait plus comment faire voilà donc il
faut qu'il se reforme il faut qu'il se
qu'il ait la pétance mais la pétanque
est rien et moi je le vois parce que
j'interviens dans des dans des centres
de formation de jeunes jeunes artisans
on parlait des jeunes architectes mais
les jeunes artisans c'est la même chose
ils ont envie ils sont dans leur temps
ça les intéresse donc en fait la matière
est là voilà et
je
dérive sur ce sujet là pour parler du
coup parce qu'effectivement c'est
revenir plusieurs reprises le coût plus
important des rénovations sur le
patrimoine alors il y a plusieurs
raisons effectivement c'est que tant
qu'il sera plus intéressant d'aller moi
je viens de Bretagne donc tant qu'il
sera plus intéressant d'aller construire
dans ta chambre patate ou dans un champ
de pomme de terre plutôt qu'en
centre-ville on aura des difficultés à
faire venir les à mobiliser à faire
venir les investisseurs c'est la réalité
le van enfin le les
moi j'ai enfin voilà je pense que on va
dans un temps où ça c'est fini on est on
est dans là on est dans l'histoire
ancienne et on va dire voilà aujourd'hui
les problématiques elles sont
différentes et cette question du coup je
pense que effectivement le coup peut
être plus important pas toujours on peut
faire des économies substantielles en
faisant notre travail d'architecte avec
les avec les porteurs de projets mais
néanmoins travailler en centre ancien
c'est plus compliqué il y a les
problèmes
les matériaux sont pas les mêmes
aujourd'hui ils sont mais posons-nous la
question en tout cas je vous invite à
vous poser la question et à nous poser
la question de à qui profite ce coup
parce que quand moi je parle avec les
menuisiers monuments historiques avec
qui je travaille et puis qui compare
leur boulot avec les poseurs de fenêtres
en fait on s'aperçoit que un menuisier
monument historique ou patrimoine il va
chercher son bois localement il le
travaille c'est du temps humain le coût
c'est du temps humain donc la fenêtre
elle va coûter beaucoup plus cher mais
c'est du temps humain donc c'est du
temps
mon délocalisable local non
dénoncialisables ce sont des compétences
ce sont des matériaux locaux on parlait
du biosourcer ça peut l'être voilà alors
que quand on pose avec des méthodes
industrielles souvent ce sont des
produits internationaux construit de
manière internationale et donc le coût
c'est-à-dire l'argent produit par ces
travaux et dispersés au niveau
international alors que quand on
travaille sur le patrimoine de la bonne
manière le coût finalement il est
réinjecté dans l'économie
mais ça c'est quelque chose qui est
difficile effectivement à intégrer et
quand on regarde simplement la question
finale c'est-à-dire combien ça coûte
pour l'usager on a du mal à modéliser en
fait tout voilà et on pourrait modéliser
la même chose et puis je m'arrêterai là
parce que sinon on va aller trop loin
mais on pourrait aussi modéliser le même
sujet sur on a parlé tout à l'heure du
coup énergétique fin des de l'énergie
grise du bâti enfin de quel est
l'empreinte écologique on disait
effectivement quand on réhabilite de
l'ancien on oublie déjà toute la partie
construction c'est à dire le bâti est
déjà là mais quand on rénove avec des
solutions industrielles avec du
polystyrène par exemple quand on fait
l'isolation par l'extérieur avec quand
on met des fenêtres en PVC leur coût de
production leur coût énergétique de
production est beaucoup plus important
que les solutions dont vous parliez tout
à l'heure voilà donc on a un coût
énergétique beaucoup plus important et
on a une capacité de vie du de ces
matériaux et de ses bâtiments qui est de
ces voilà l'isolation par extérieur par
exemple c'est 15 ans voilà au mieux
voilà donc on est donc donc dans 15 ans
faudra réinjecter la même voilà et donc
finalement ce coût énergétique du bâti
alors comment Christine Leconte vous en
parliez tout à l'heure et lors des
architectes le dit beaucoup mieux que
moi mais
ce coût énergétique du bâti et de la
solution industrielle du bâti à mon avis
doit être doit être interrogé voilà
voilà et puis j'ai entendu quand même
puis je terminerai là-dessus enfin la
question de voilà la vie de la BDF parce
que faut en dire un mot
comme je l'ai dit effectivement
nous sommes très sollicités plus nous
sommes sollicités et plus il est
difficile pour nous de
se rendre disponible en amont pour faire
du conseil pour discuter avec le porteur
de projet avec les élus que que vous
êtes et pourtant sont les consignes qui
nous sont données à charge François et
on y souscrit complètement parce qu'on
pense que c'est comme ça qu'on peut
faire le travail voilà alors après pour
répondre plus directement à votre
question il y a des outils c'est à dire
que les sites patrimoniaux remarquables
sont des outils qui permettent de se
mettre autour de la table et de de
convenir ensemble de la règle voilà donc
à partir du moment où on est dans ces
logiques là il y a pas d'appréciation
possible et puis il y a et là je salue
comment le
les directives là qui qui ont et qui
sont qui ont qui nous ont été qui nous
ont été proposés par la ministre et
voilà
sous l'égide du Ministère de la Culture
et puis du ministère de la transition
écologique parce qu'effectivement
jusqu'à présent on avait peu de
directives de niveau national voilà et
je pense qu'effectivement c'est
important pour mieux faire comprendre le
cadre dans lequel nous travaillons parce
que nous nous le savons mais vous vous
le savez pas voilà et donc pour mieux
faire comprendre ce cadre dans lequel
nous travaillons ces directives
nationales me semble-t-il sont une
réponse et sont une réponse importante
voilà
profitons de votre présence pour
poser la question le même si c'est pas
en lien direct avec le thème du jour
mais sur la petite incise de nos
collègues députés sur la vie conforme
des ABS dans le cadre des projets de loi
énergie renouvelables votre point de vue
sur la façon dont les conséquences que
ça peut avoir sur le travail
du juge mais bon voilà mais en même
temps voilà alors effectivement ça peut
ça pose des questions ça voilà on a nous
sommes agités bon voilà alors
si nous nous souvenons si nous nous
souvenons bien en 2010 au moment du
Grenelle de l'environnement vous savez
on a supprimé la zppp puis on a recréé
la vape quand on a recréé la vape on a
demandé à ce que les avables et à ce que
le travail des architectes des bâtiments
de France dans le cadre de la vape soit
fait en prenant en compte le départ à
l'époque c'était le développement
durable mais bon ça revient un petit peu
c'est un petit peu au même voilà bon je
pense que ce sont des des voilà ce sont
des préoccupations évidemment que l'on a
mais vous le savez
voilà de là à dire que avec 4000 avis
par an on va pouvoir argumenter chaque
chaque avis que l'on va faire en prenant
en compte une politique qui se qui
s'inscrivent niveau national et dont on
a au mieux la déclinaison au niveau
régional non clairement on peut enfin
c'est on va dire en droit concrètement
moi je voilà je sais pas comment faire
par contre ce que je sais c'est que ça
donne voilà ça enfin ça donne ça donne
un message voilà bon
merci mesdames messieurs pour les
réponses que vous avez apportées à nos
préoccupations et vous avez compris que
c'était pour nous un sujet
de Cours mais aussi de long terme donc
on suivra bien entendu avec vous
l'évolution de ce sujet merci beaucoup
merci